two
hello my friends my family hello it's
Friday it's April 21st it's a sunny
beautiful day spring may I say even
summer
is close upon us you may I may say that
you may consider it thank you which is
exciting you know summer's always fun
you know that's something to look
forward to today's episode is sponsored
by Kudos Kudos Shopify and PayPal honey
thank you to our wonderful sponsors
[Applause]
uh listen
yeah listen also Zuck is a soul-sucking
demon hell yeah it's on teddyfresh.com
right now listen today's episode is
quite the Bonanza we're I've been super
excited for this episode all week these
guys have put in a tremendous amount of
work to stake their claim on this 620
000 windfall that we got from the idiots
at bbtv I can't wait who's crying over
their bankruptcy filing as we uh skip
our way through
through uh lavish travels of the world
so uh thank you to them by the way thank
you Google
also we're doing uh guess who's High
which is a 420 tradition
now how what's the plan with that one
how many of y'all are getting high do I
know
what's the name of the game okay oh I
just want to see is there a number are
you trying to get in our heads it's
gonna be one could it be zero I mean it
could be zero it could be everybody or
anything in between big old doinks
come on what you want a hint I do
hit me
it won't be who you expect
that'd be awesome
totally wouldn't expect that right
um so that's exciting so you guys said
you want to do this and I think that's
Brave of y'all you want to do the Guess
Who is high before indeed oh really
which frankly would scare me but uh I'm
not I'm not the one getting high
although the one idea I do like is that
part of av's presentation is this insane
spread back there bro yeah
of Lebanese food uh it's Persian but
dude I want I want to get in on that
yeah can we just start the show with
ab's presentation and then do the how
high and then everybody else
whatever you want I'm kidding you the
boss I won't do that
yeah by the way uh Ela says she looks
like a filter
that's what you have but you should know
right did somebody say that and I should
have known but that's funny that's funny
but I just I see on the camera I see
more like detail and then on here I look
like a filter
do I look like I have a filter on that's
a compliment because you always look
freaking everyone looks bomb with those
filters and you look amazing you should
stunt on them a little bit hey Gabe one
sec bud you want to show it off I mean
it's always so hard to show I'm gonna
stunt on my Instagram later well give us
a tutorial
I'm a tick tocker now by the way will
you sing me Happy Birthday Mr President
me oh
let's see I thought you were talking to
Gabe I'm JFK
um no I don't I don't think I was
following American culture back then so
I don't know that yeah JFK in Maryland
uh they they
they did it she [__] the president
they did yeah
[Laughter]
really yes and did she [__] like his
brother too she was like kind of
he was racking them up yeah I don't know
if they were ever confirmed because
weren't they like affairs
yeah these are they were always just
rumors but the JFK thing was for sure
yeah but it was still that's pretty hype
though like and JFK was a heartthrob too
wasn't he the president did love that
also you're you're your nails look
awesome they've got like Hardware yeah I
got chains let's go and I can do SMR
ASMR ASMR yeah
very good Gabe how are you today
okay I just want to wish you guys a
Happy 420 baby
[Applause]
happy 420 again
please [__]
[__] [__] Hot Box my [__]
baby
[Music]
take a fat rip blow it up my ass and
then I'll breathe it out my nose [__]
do you ever smoke Gabe do you blaze at
all
I just do cigars have you ever smelled
weed
but it's not good for I don't like it
you don't like it you tried it you
didn't like it
yeah yeah I'm the same way Gabe I'm not
a big fan of it but a lot of people
partake and we love that for them don't
we
oh it's good it's it's up to them it
depends on their body my body can't
handle the smoke of weed right I smoke
and I it gave me the bad bad runs
smoking weed gives you diarrhea
what they put on it
oh that's interesting diarrhea
are you sure it was weed you smoked
it's it's something like that was it
oregano or something
okay what are you doing this weekend
well
work on this we're gonna mix some
spaghetti and my boss
and my balls
spaghetti again
so you'll be serving your balls to your
family this weekend
so gross along with
along with spaghetti of course
it's my favorite after Friday it's pasta
Friday baby sucking my balls [__]
from my balls and eat it through the
grill baby
put marinara up my ass and then suck on
my balls [__]
oh
look at them look at the marinara from
my ass and lick it
right
always so great to start the show like
that
[Applause]
I'm good at this
all right get those balls cooking I know
there's there's a slow cook kind of
process you know make sure they're nice
and juicy for the family okay
all right yeah
some fry sperm that is interesting let's
not have you trim I mean mythical Chef
uh Jeff available for some experiments
all right Gabe we love you have a great
weekend okay bud
for 20. happy 420 beer
[Music]
oh
[__]
[__] [__]
okay fine I'm hanging up now
[__] bye Gabe
there it is oh love is like doing a
Morpheus today
I don't know I don't know what the vibe
is
red pill to [__] [__]
well let's see here Where Do We Begin I
guess we've got maybe we should do some
top of the show stuff and then at the 30
Minute Market into the who's High sounds
good is that food Gonna Last baby or
should we actually get into it it should
be good yeah it'll sit there for like an
hour hour now
um just be realistic that I mean it's
sealed off but it might not be the best
should we do it we could do your
presentation right now
well you know I don't want the food to
go bad okay
it'll be good oh so okay so you says it
will be good I think it'll be good yeah
okay
because before you were implying it
wouldn't be good I mean it's not going
to be as good as if it was like
completely fresh yeah this will be a
good argument for doing it right now
okay not a lot of enthusiasm for that
idea I'm gonna follow Dan's
sleep what do you want to do oh I I'm
always stick to the plan you know but um
if Ethan's hungry which I think is what
this is really about then we can do abs
now no we'll wait we'll wait put your
balls in my mouth excuse me Zachary uh
actually Zach's not here today oh yeah I
discovered something yeah
where is he it's Lou baby you don't
recognize me
like this one came out
he comes out on Mondays but it's a
special occasion okay hold on okay uh
Lou Excuse me yes is Lou gonna be doing
the presentation today or Zach
both
wow that sounds scary
this is a Dr Jekyll Mrs hi yeah I drank
my potion and uh you know Dr Jekyll and
Mr Hyde Dr jacking of a movie Sweet Life
of Jeff and Cody
the Magnificent Tales
all right very good Lou welcome to the
show nice thank you thank you
[Applause]
does it right there on your shirt
all right what is this someone made up
oh
a cartoon of everybody eating my poo uh
that doesn't sound that great but uh uh
just take a look think kind of crazy
this weekend guys oh yeah oh I saw a
shredder eating his own [__] and that
got me thinking maybe [__] tastes good
so the next time I chat I ate it turn it
off wait are you for real yeah and I
have some for you guys to try all
different flavors wait this isn't a joke
you actually ate poop wait a second
uh-huh that's [__] delicious tastes a
little like pesto this is nice the
[__] wrong with you all you're
literally eating feces human fecal
matter you're wrong Dan this [__] slays
you know this is some real good fika I
like how creamy it is and the way it
slides down your throat oh it tastes
like jerky I've never had poop before
but this might be the best thing I've
ever tasted in my life yeah I gotta say
Dan don't knock it till you try it it's
so good hey Ryan Cavanaugh here I gotta
say Ethan despite our differences this
poop is the most delicious thing I've
ever consumed and I [__] love it
thank you Ethan for this wonderful gift
to the world see Dan Everyone likes it
yeah Dan stop being such a hater okay
fine if you want me to try it so bad I
will
good morning
oh sound noises
well
wow yes so uh I love it I watched that
apparently I don't know how much work
went in that because it's all AI
generated voice right yeah I've never
done that is that a lot of work to
Crunch though yes it is it's pretty hard
because you need like training footage
where the voices are clean
no background noise so well there's
plenty thankfully there's hours and
hours and hours of that for all of us so
but I will say that it's a very on
character for each one
I almost feel like uh
I feel like an AI could do this show
frankly
they got the sound bites down they got
all the characters I was like [__] man
so okay shout out to whoever put so much
time into that test
[Music]
there it is
I'm sorry we love that I'm afraid I
can't do that I want to say welcome back
to AB officially on the show oh thank
you so much glad to be back
oh yes he's back uh he's back
triumphantly from Creator Clash
uh I told AB I can't believe that Lena
might be doing it and he said well I
can't say no to her and I was like I'm
gonna say it so Lena don't do it wait
wait don't do it well hold on AV got to
do this two times and now we're all
telling Lena don't do it not all I'm
saying don't do it literally the thought
of Lena getting her because you want to
die no Lena you should be scared for her
opponent that's true
damn pituitary glands jiggling out there
boy thank you thank you Ethan for your
confidence in me I am really pumped I'll
say that
I'm gonna need to be there physically
because if somebody if somebody does
something to Lena I'm gonna step in the
ring myself yeah
I don't know if I'll be able to watch I
would love for ILO to be there with me
ringside right there it'd be perfect all
the support I need is her coach
give her that water bottle squirt no
absolutely it should be in her Corner
that'd be cool yeah maybe just you
I can do that yeah that'd be cool to see
you on TV okay
if you really don't want to come up to
it on TV you know
wow
Raider Clash is a big event
I'll be your reporter on on the field
so is this a this is a real possibility
have you spoken uh seriously with them
Lena about this no not like officially
um but I have been practicing and
training so if if I had the job I don't
want to reach or push but if I do get
the opportunity I would definitely take
it
how are you feeling you feel good your
form feels good you're out there you're
throwing you're throwing heaters
honestly I haven't like officially
sparred with anyone yet because my my
training wasn't intended for that
um but I've just been like learning the
sport and the technique and and that's
honestly been so hard like I didn't know
how much technique is involved so the
past couple months it's just been all
about that
AB how's her technique looking
it's funny uh lean is definitely more
athletic than I am
um but uh Wally says that I've he always
told me I've never seen a [__]
who does this or does this he like when
I first started myself my arm would go
out and he's like you know now that I
meet your wife she's the only other
person that does all the [__] that you
do
[Laughter]
well besides that he says that he said
he did tell me that he thinks she could
be really good actually oh god really
freaking crazy oh my God defeated yeah
that's what I that's what I need in my
life that's crazy you guys okay I'll
bring honor back to the podcast
against you baby you know that oh yeah
who's it against
this [__] household
over this [__] shame you know a Ramadan
finished recently right yeah today yeah
oh nice happy Mook bar thank you happy
Aid how do you did I say it right uh
Obama
[Music]
everybody
well that's exciting what is it again I
mean you can eat now right yeah good
Lena can you say it again
[Applause]
all right well moving on uh coming
through the top here James Charles
um
continues to get owned publicly
and to be totally honest with you
what the [__] I just don't understand
this man
uh he posted a video he says I slept in
my makeup and here's what happened
uh this guy commented you don't have the
income coming in anymore you don't have
income coming in anymore
by the way some random [__] dude on
Twitter I mean if you're responding to
these kinds of tweets you're not in a
good headspace that's my theory
wait who is responding James responds to
this tweet
okay okay he doesn't have Twitter
premium like [__] L dude
I'm gonna take him seriously uh he says
quick let's compare bank accounts oh my
God bruh dude come on bro that is just
pathetic like have some dignity for
yourself man
this is almost more embarrassing than
trying to [__] 16 year old boys oh well
okay
okay show Okay show your bank account
James I mean I'll I'll look at it I'm
curious how much is in there
uh then uh he says let's compare
interaction with miners first meet zero
oh you many cases and still going wow
and again this man has a humiliation
fetish clearly
he does it's not just
armpit here he loves
uh it's also humiliation and then after
that he bails he deletes it and emails
he deletes it yeah
you can't just let it slide please
not the crazy huh so I have to order
this medication I'm not just on my phone
during the show oh Ela is getting
um no yeah we can do an update if you
want next Friday right
um
the a will be transferred back
into my body
it's got one girl in it
the egg is apparently rated
for a a whatever that means yeah
unless chat gbt what's the hierarchy of
egg ratings but apparently that's a good
rating
now put that phone down
Friday would be the pregnancy test it's
just so crazy
yeah um
okay yeah what's the what's the system
where they grade baseball cards
um I mean PSA yeah it's a company that
does it yeah so they sent the egg out to
them and
I think that's nearly meant condition
actually I'm actually curious on the
hierarchy I'm asking chat gbt GPS up
regarding uh how would you call that uh
IVF
yes yeah
so let's see here 4aa is indeed a good
rating
IVF embryo grading is a way for uh
embryologists to assess quality and the
potential success for implantation
okay the guard The Gardener rating
system is commonly used Gardner that's
what this is Gardner okay like you're
planning goddamn seeds in the soil uh
so expansion and hatching says this
represent is represented by number one
through six where one indicates early
blastocyst and six means a hatched
blastocyst I don't know the [__] that
means bro a grade 4 implies an expanded
blastocyst
y'all anyone
I don't know what the [__] that means uh
except the building constructed
across does this mean inner math cell is
represented by the early stage of the
embryo
blastocyst so is that that's not
necessarily
an indicator of quality it's just the
the stage of how how deep it is yep okay
so Forge right in the middle that's good
I think you know
so then the Inner Cell mass is
represented by a b or c a being the best
quality
get at me
you got the dude you got those good ass
eggs girl you got that all right you got
that pasture raised grass-fed
and it puts them see me now no
uh grade A signifies that themselves are
tightly packed
like badass
laughs
thank you Tropa termic quality
is also represented by letter a b or c a
being the best quality yo you bought
like a perfect egg it's a perfect egg
you got a freaking perfect egg right
there girl okay
yeah so as we as we talked about we only
have one girl out of the seven or eight
seven six boys one girl and so the the
doctor wanted to do a test run for a
month yes but we decided we don't want
to do it because it's just it's so much
on my body it's like it's hard I've been
taking this
um Mana pure shot every day and it's
just I hate it so much I really I hope
for her I have a pretty good tolerance
for pain yeah you do but this one really
hurts me I don't know if it's like that
for everybody so the liquid it's not the
needle the liquid inside Burns and my
whole stomach is sore right now
you all
you look so like it looks like it's
torching you so I didn't want to do it
you have to do it every night yeah and
what is it just juices up your it's
hormones it makes you
um yeah it makes you ovulate more I
don't know I asked her like why do I
need to ovulate more if we already have
the egg ready and fertilized and
everything and she said it's because we
still need to prepare your uterus for
when we put it back we want your body to
like take it in yes so we still need to
prepare your body for it I don't know
well it's a lot of great for me so in
two weeks we'll know if he was Prego or
not yeah it might be on the show again
because it's a Friday again that's crazy
so I'm asking chat gbt now what would
happen if a man injected himself with
menopure okay I'm curious you know what
I mean yeah what would happen and after
that I'm taking Progesterone which is
another hormone
for the next two weeks I think it it
says increased sperm production [__]
yeah
let's go increase testosterone
production let's go dude
possible side effects
headache mood swings and mood swings
that's kind of that sounds bad okay but
apparently it's not that bad I'll just
get my balls all Heavy I must love that
okay well anyway good
so that's exciting yes very exciting and
they're all so funny in that um Clinic
like I went this morning for an
ultrasound and they to so today they
checked your lining I still don't know
what anything means good lining so
they're like your lining is gorgeous
that's good I mean I'm looking at the
screen thank you girl it's gorgeous
gorgeous
I remember when you gave birth I'll also
say this uh and I'm sorry if It
embarrasses you but I'll just say it
they were raving about your nipples yeah
the
the nurses could not stop every time a
new nurse would come in and they'd be
like you have perfect nipples that's
amazing I disagree one they'd be like
Earl your nibbles are so perfect I must
have heard that ten times
I don't know what they're on about those
ladies well crazy perfect little bites
you know yeah that's enough okay
fair enough
yeah but you're like a perfect baby
Factory I mean truly so good after this
baby we're closing the factory yeah I'm
kind of like I'm so happy right now with
where I'm at with my body and I'm like
I'm really gonna do this to myself again
you're gonna get like this giant yeah
because you've really been feeling
yourself on your Instagram and yeah so
starting to see those abs forming I know
you're absolutely looking good damn but
I'll do it again
so are you is your plan how do you
implant uh plan to incorporate being
pregnant onto this new social yeah
that's it's given me a little bit of um
anxiety because I'm really loving what
I'm doing right now and I hope I can
still do it so my hope is to still do
like fun fashion moments pregnant I
think you can do it I just hope that
I'll still film myself like I am now
because if I feel like I don't look good
then it's not going to be fun right well
reread it right
sorry baby
as my wife we're talking about
I think you'll pull it off it'll be fun
actually it'd be like a fun little uh
challenge yeah it's a challenge yeah
it's very exciting it'll be fun for you
I'm already starting to contribute to
the like Artistry of the photo yeah I'm
starting to think about it like that how
can I make it look cool I can be sick
yeah
so there's that you know lots of good
stuff happening there
now I don't know what kind of [__]
this is on the suburb Dan's not even
here but it's about him now I am very
very much against this
people are starting to feel bad for Dan
because of the Scorpion chair I think
he's done his time
um time for a normal chair they say he
has done his time on the seat the bit
has paid for itself let him have a
proper chair and desk again I don't
think you guys even want the normal
chair back
he'll come back but I think he'd say yes
I think he would have said yes a long
time ago he did get a little cushion
that made it a little easier but yeah
we'd have to ask him but you know I
think he's so plugged into this setup I
can't imagine him anyway look at all the
monitors yeah and it's like
yeah honestly who even is he without the
Scorpion chair I don't know Justin Dan
just any other than the wizard status
is gone yeah without the Scorpion chair
Dan
do you do you want a different chair
sorry about that
um right the Reddit post about uh the
chair listen
the gag is pretty good but
this chair
has started to affect my life
okay okay it hurts my back oh your back
hurts I'd sit in this uh five days a
week for hours and hours at a time
especially when we're live and I don't
know if you've ever noticed but during
the show I like stand up and get up a
lot because if I don't I'm like
seriously my like legs are falling
asleep it's okay
so maybe the solution isn't to get you a
normal chair but to bring in some kind
of ergonomic uh engineer if we could
make a modification to it to make it
less horrible uh I'm happy to keep it I
mean I like the aspect of all of the
screens like right it's cool but you can
do that with the normal disc I think we
should mod it
if you want to do that I'm open to I'm
open to suggestion I think the part of
the joke is that it's like a Transformer
we keep building on it yeah but listen I
mean I I lobbied for this chair I made
my own bed here and you spent a lot of
money on it and so
how long has it been
it's been years now it's been years
maybe like two years I guess it was like
two years ago we got it I will say Dan
has been a good sport he doesn't
complain that much about it no uh not to
us at least but knowing he has back pain
that that is a problem yeah also he's
hit his head on it so many times yeah
dangerous like genuine like to make it
badass and scorpion-like you see how
like there's like points everywhere like
all over it is like sharp metal points
and so even at like when Theodore elbow
on it and [__] yeah I put a tennis ball
on the end for Theodore it's like right
at face level yeah gnarly metal Spike
I'm like this is not a greatly conceived
uh chair
that being said West Coast Customs or
something someone like that maybe could
help us
maybe not be outside their normal
purview but Dan would be pretty sweet
okay so what about something like this I
mean get a cushion I mean I have a
cushion I have this thing I've done
things that have made it a little bit
better but it's just if you're back
then
perhaps something to let you lay down
and
well theoretically this one can do that
but it's it's not really that
comfortable in the laying down position
it's not giving me a hospital you can't
see me when I when I lean it back so
how much is this one
this is a real product
got it why that's just why
yeah
it says between twelve thousand and
twenty thousand oh man this one
definitely looks pretty clean though
dude who is their customer
I I'm convinced we're the only one who's
ever bought it yeah yeah maybe
would you upgrade would you change for
this perhaps
I mean maybe
I mean what did it say twelve thousand
to twenty thousand I mean I got BB TV
money can you trade in like a used car
record it yeah that's a good idea trade
this up
could try
this is awesome I think it'd be awesome
if you were laying down the whole show
and there's like a top-down camera
well again I mean theoretically we could
do this but that's also kind of like oh
[__] that's not going to be comfortable
that's [__] funny I actually I think
I found a good replacement I just sent
it in uh what you got licensed in the
wrong the thing is that you guys do the
show so much
so like he actually sits in it for hours
right yeah and I mean this is this
computer is like my work computer too so
even when we're not live I'm sitting
here so I'll say this trip for hours a
day if you wanted to share I'm fully in
support of that Dan but we will need to
get you something special because you
are our captain so to speak for our
first mate first officer first officer
EXO yeah and so I think that we need
something like this for you if you want
a new chair
[Music]
yeah I think I think we joked about this
one oh my god oh it's VR it's VR so
when I hit the button it should send Dan
and I'll [__] reject me yeah ejected
from this job
now how much is this we looked into this
I don't believe this is actually I think
that was like proof of concept or break
because I would consider buying them
just up like two hundred thousand dollar
super Advanced AI stand spinning the
whole episode yeah
it's not reading chat then then we'll
just go do some trick to get your
attention oh [__] I'm 100 serious bro
you're not getting that you're not
getting into a normal chair
[Laughter]
it's like just get out of the house at
that point go to a theme park
there is no way that that is fun
zero I disagree okay I'll give you my
you're gonna need a full maintenance
person for this chair right exactly it
looks fun now me and you did a VR thing
remember on the battleship yeah and when
it goes upside down and does all these
crazy angles while it looks fun remember
you're not a piece of wood bro like your
body gets you get jostled around yeah
it's it's painful I'm getting nauseous
just looking at it oh
you know and and those those harnesses
aren't a hundred percent tight so you're
falling yeah they're getting thrown
around it's crazy it's not good
[Music]
what's this
okay
wait they're in the same room wait chill
it's just a torture device
and then one fundamentally new product
so are people supposed to buy this for
their house like what is the idea here
exactly and then this is instead of like
a death penalty this is gonna be the new
the new punishment oh my God
like genuinely curious what is this
website
[Music]
the only way to experience everything on
your own skin the only way
if you thought you stand firmly it's
time to who are they
who are they they must be twins right
why are they there they're the
dominatrix to uh
while you're in the chair what are they
supposed to be like the flight
stewardess Maybe
I don't know the Medics they're the
twins in The Shining what the [__] I'm
one as virtual reality
emotion as a gift as a gift
gift
okay let's see now I'm curious is this
mm company a real I don't think it's
real they have a weapon I don't think
any of those are real not secure by the
way
ww88.mm bro
the domain doesn't even exist yeah I
know wait I think we just got uh all of
our passwords leaked yeah [__]
oh [__] that's funny
shame
put the chair in resin is that a
possibility Sam that's just the entire
thing I mean
we could get like professional
you don't think so
no I'm sure you could do it but it is
it's a horrible idea why
what are you gonna do like
how are you gonna get it out of this
room well we'll cross that bridge when
we get there it's just gonna be a giant
like we can cut off look how big this is
it would have to be like enormous I'll
tell you how we'll cut a hole in the
ceiling and lift it out by crane
obviously Dan
uh
I do think it's like Mobility Mary's
chair though like I would have done
anything to salvage that and what we're
supposed to just throw this thing out
then
let's get Aiden wrong of course we can
hang on to it we could use it for gags
or hey we could do a a giveaway to fans
you could get the Scorpion shirt right
that's gonna be it that would be huge
I'm sure they'll love to uh oh people
would def some people would be down yeah
and you'll have to pay to uh to ship it
on your own rights by the way well
before we do that let's get Aiden Ross
out here to at least sniff the chair
before we say goodbye to it
um
a request for Olivia
you know
ever since Olivia presented the Gomez
conspiracy document
she's become the
the drama keeper now here they're
requesting Leah Michelle
that is a good one I don't know who that
is she was on Glee
oh is that the girl who's like supposed
to be like a giant b word yeah and after
all of the rumors of her being a b word
came out then the internet like really
doubled down on the fake conspiracy that
she can't read and there's weirdly a lot
of evidence showcasing that she can't
read when it was just like it was pulled
from nowhere pretty much how can you be
an actor that can't read though that
doesn't make any sense that's the thing
is like there's reasons and there are
ways to get around that for one Lea
Michele is only in Ryan like usually
only in Ryan Murphy stuff apparently he
whispers the lines into her ear right
before all right I'm into this
conspiracy I love it you got me yeah I
think that's a great idea okay for sure
I think we're doing uh I'm gonna I'm
trying to learn everything I can about
Vanderpump that's good yeah we need to
be caught up on that yeah yeah
it's a new world for me but
it's a good world how are you enjoying
the world of Vanderpump I love the drama
you know me yeah yeah
very good
moving on we've got uh this dude this is
crazy
Elon Musk is pushing Twitter blue hard
everybody lost their verification did
you know that no yesterday was I guess
Crystal knock of uh
Twitter verifications
they went door-to-door ripping
ripping it from our hands and uh that's
Auschwitz the thing that's funny to me
is
what is the point of removing the
verified from these celebrity accounts
because there's not that many
it's just making it unusable now because
I used to check my verified
notifications well that's been useless
since the people could buy yeah yeah
uh but here here's something here's an
interesting update just before the purge
yesterday there was 19 489
of the 407 000 Legacy verified accounts
I had identified in early April had
Twitter blue
today that number for those accounts is
nineteen thousand four hundred and
ninety seven for a net increase of 28
accounts
so is that real that's crazy he says
he's got the API he confirmed it
apparently who is this guy
oh just some random dude
so I don't know man and then the new
thing on Twitter is
now like all these conservative conserva
restarts
can I say conserva no no
I'll type it and you tell me right no we
can tell what you're going to type okay
that's not good that's not good
but we say this word the lib blank
people say that all the time
I mean yeah of course you can yeah
at least he sends it you know what
you're talking about
dude
I don't know
so anyways what were you saying I was
just saying that I don't really
understand the whole strategy here
because I don't either oh yeah the
conservatives are shaming people now who
are like I'm not paying eight dollars
for that [__] they go dude you're
[__] cheat bro
what are you poor it's become like a
status symbol or the principle pull up
pull up the Tweet of the guy who did
like the whole
Freedom declaration because he's paying
for Twitter blue
they're celebrities like bye I'm not
paying eight dollars for this he's like
dude you cheap [__] millionaire
celebrity don't want to pay eight
dollars like dude I don't want to pay
into Elon Musk patreon I'm sorry thank
you Dan for that joke
oh so it's a whole thing now I see it's
trending payday eight pay the eight
this okay now I assure you I've done
some research this is a real tweet these
are real people this MF paid for Twitter
no I didn't pay for Twitter I paid for
free speech I paid for 1776 to commence
again
a war with Britain I paid for the found
founding father's Vision I paid to tell
Silicon Valley go screw itself uh are
you talking about Elon Musk you are
paying Twitter idiot all right [__]
idiot
cool
I pay the show support for a man who put
himself in the line of fire for the
First Amendment oh
Elon Musk the person that started
blocking us for making jokes
I paid because we support our own I paid
because if George Washington was a life
that he'd be paying too
yeah right
so next time you say I paid for Twitter
just realize how ignorant
the [__] you sound
no I'm sorry
that's a grown ass man dude
[__] Americans baby eight bucks bro
hell no
I thought people were going through hard
times now we're just spending eight
dollars on to give a billionaire money
like all of a sudden these people can't
afford the eight bucks
that's crazy
so I guess pay the eight is the
conservative rally
what do you know about the the alternate
rally
my the block the blue the blue somebody
made a plug-in that you can install in
your browser it'll auto block anybody oh
my God I'm that's not a bad idea and I'm
very sorry about that uh too it's just
crazy that it's all of them you guys are
all all these dorks have Twitter blue
all of them
what are you talking about oh you don't
no no what the hell no never okay oh you
did that's my boy the problem is that we
like us the verified people the real
ones
we used to be able to make connections
like that we met so many people that way
because you check your verified
notifications and then you see oh this
YouTuber that I watched followed me and
then you start talking in the DMS that's
the only reason really that I actually
like Twitter I agree but that's the
actual useful part of it you now you
don't have it you and Ethan don't have
check marks anymore so what are the
rules answer me this so Zach what does a
check mark mean
no
[Applause]
if I don't have a check mark what does
it mean
don't you understand I if I don't have
the check mark it means nothing to you
peasants
look dude
I got my blue Jackie I don't care how I
did it it's still there okay it doesn't
have to go any deeper than that I'll say
I'll say this I [__] hate it I really
wish it wasn't around I would because
especially now because I feel like I
could have just got it legit
but you know if it gives me an advantage
we'll never know
you've got a legit Twitter check I think
so I'm being persecuted now I'm being
persecuted hold on did Ian you got the
legit blue Chucky he did on Instagram
only on Instagram and no one's talking
about they ruined that one too yeah
oh my God although the blue check on
Instagram wasn't didn't have as much no
as much usability but the the Instagram
you can't even click on it and see who
paid or who who didn't it's just it's
across the board it's just a check crazy
it's more expensive on Instagram too
lame yeah super although you I guess you
get like customer support which is at
least like a decent service I guess
I mean I've never used it what are you
gonna ask Instagram Instagram customer
support
hey uh
can you all stop like serving me
ads for cancer
you'll need customer support because all
these people are impersonating you with
their paid check marks so it actually
helps that's true that's a good service
so why do you why do you hold on to the
blue check baby the chat's asking about
what advantage my stuff is get a lot
more engagement recently since they did
that then he straight up said and Elon
said that they would be pushing
uh verified users first
I don't know I loved you but because
you're not terrified and you've been
getting lots of Engagement too yeah I've
been getting massive juicers and also
last time we spoke about this
uh Abu said that and I looked on Twitter
and it said uh engagement increase
coming soon so it wasn't on last time
we're talking about it on the show
I think you're just juicing yeah you're
just juicing my bro yeah
you want to juice I could take or leave
the Twitter one it's just the [__]
platform's going downhill bottom line
[__] hate it I really do I mean
especially like the verify tab I can't
see [__] I really cannot see [__] so now
knowing that hasn't even been
implemented yet can I count on you to
cancel your Twitter blue subscription
it's implemented since like a month back
but last time we spoke about it it
wasn't implemented so you were juicing
before that was on okay your original
organic baby I don't care about it
well apparently you guys might get Mass
blocked by people now too just for
having it so yeah it might actually hurt
your engagement I'll cancel it right now
thank you Zach uh thank you that's a
good man you're a man you know what
that's because Lou's here listen in my
opinion we need to embarrass and shame
people to not paying I'm sorry we need
to be the uh
we need to oppose this movement
thank you
on Instagram too when you filter by
verified people that paid for the
verification don't show up in the
verification filter
so oh that's good
so it's worthless in that listen tick
tock's the only real social media
platform left
for the People by the people
it's a good communist organization
People's Republic of China exactly for
the People by the people I just canceled
it it says expires May 9th so um
oh
take that Eon the numbers going down
[__] just in time for your concert
you'll be checklist by the time of your
show yes that's a new version of
verified no checking let's go that's it
it kind of is that's real Rockstar
you're telling me President Biden is he
verified you know what I mean he's got
the gray check oh he's got a gray one
yeah for like government officials
oh a gray one okay so the podcast still
has a gold checkie too that's kind of
fire what is that one for businesses I
gotta tell you no it's gone
[Music]
oh right I was thinking that it would
probably disappear because I think they
want to charge like uh a business yeah
like five thousand dollars a month or
something for for one of the yellow
checkies yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I got how much it is but it's like
an absurd amount like that oh my God
yeah I heard that too business check
mark Twitter cost yeah
a thousand a month what
and what do you get for that a yellow
chick nothing yeah
dude don't be cheap bro pay the thousand
a month
come on Nike you could afford a thousand
dollars a month
I mean I don't I don't really see any
benefits in it other than having the
blue check but but now it means nothing
you understand it it used to mean
something right because it verified
people
that they removed it from the verified
people right removed any meaning it has
and then gave it to a bunch of randoms
right you know what I what I'd like
though is like a little like gold Lego
brick that'd be cool that's fine yeah I
I right that makes big money for that
wait listen to this so not only do you
pay a thousand dollars per month for the
gold yeah verified you have to pay an
additional fifty dollars per month for
any Affiliated person
um
that's so expensive yeah what software
do you pay that kind of money for 50
like super super high end yeah analytics
or some kind of super business plug-in
with like high level customer support
it's expensive
uh
I don't believe that that comes with any
service either
so
I've seen people with official companies
and if they're a part of that
organization they can get like a
we could get like an A2 podcast check
mark everyone employed yeah it costs 50
per person yeah
it's crazy
what the [__]
so there it is uh
yes
but uh despite all that there are still
people who want to pay the eight dollars
God bless him
hey something changed and you know I see
no reason Zach I'm surprised you folded
so quick I'm kind of over it I feel I
mean if it was just for the blue check
then yeah yeah
I don't give a [__] about the engagement
I just use it for you know promo and
stuff but Zach's playing Roxy the 14th
13th 13th thank you appreciate it don't
go on the 14th don't go on the market
that there you go there's your promo
thank you thank you appreciate it thank
you you pay me the eight dollars oh
gladly
maybe paid me eight dollars a month I'll
promote whatever you want
see this is a good deal I think it's a
better deal yeah for sure do you know
how much people pay for a sponsor
right yeah I'm more than eight bucks
this is a great deal all right listen
guys enough uh chit chat it's time to
get into it I'm gonna think our sponsors
real fast and then we are going to get
into these
exciting segments we had planned today
so with that being said Thank you thank
you too
our wonderful sponsor
Shopify I love Shopify
and I'm glad you're here for this Ela
because you are a Shopify alumni
not technically what
I don't know I don't know if they they
might have actual people I don't know
you're an alumni I think it just means
that you're a student veteran yeah
you're a best friend okay okay why do
you love Shopify so much
why do I love it because it's the and
that's where the teddy fresh website is
and Shopify helped us make it always
been it's been the server service that
we
um go ahead
that was our first service that we ended
up choosing to use and it just worked so
it's been there for us from the
beginning and until today it's frankly a
revolutionary platform that is helping
millions of businesses worldwide to
create e-commerce websites the thing
that's so incredible about it
is that if you're day one or in our case
you're five or six right or even in the
case of like I don't know Nike uses it
but I know a lot of these super super
like billion dollar companies are also
using Shopify yeah the customization the
ease of use the amount of plug-ins it's
incredible
they've got the processing there it's
like it's all set up there for you I
simply cannot Rave about it more
um
yeah whatever you're selling you know
selling online or even in person because
they've got the uh right they have they
got some little swipeys now
little swipey POS
yeah it covers every sales channel from
from POS systems to all-in-one
e-commerce
and even like when we did a pop-up we
were able to just rent the equipment
yeah for that day or even just borrow it
I'm not sure if it was even in with pay
um and you get the equipment for the
pop-up to charge people because straight
to your online store like how amazing is
that yeah you don't have to do any
bookkeeping or reconciliation or
anything
uh it even lets you sell across social
media marketplaces like Tick Tock
Facebook Instagram integrates everywhere
packed with industry-leading tools ready
to ignite your growth Shopify gives you
complete control over your business and
your brand without having to learn any
new skills design or code and thanks to
their 24 7 help with an extensive
Business course Library Shopify is there
to support your success every step of
the way people
um
if you have Ambitions to start your own
business if you want to just dabble in
it I highly recommend and endure Shopify
uh and now is the best time I'll tell
you why because if you sign up for a one
dollar per month trial period
you get one dollar per month trial
period at shopify.com after Dark
all lowercase
go to shopify.com after dark to take
your business to the next level for one
dollar per month trial period
how many dollars one
shopify.com slash after dark thank you I
love you Shopify thank you thank you
and uh next up thank you to Kudos kudos
to you my friends
Mother's Day is right around the corner
but before you buy your present online
you need to make sure that Kudos is uh
to get them
to use kudos to get the most cash back
Kudos is a free shopping extension that
not only helps you pick the best credit
card or card to use at checkout but it
also doubles your rewards on over 15 000
sites that means if you usually earn
three percent back when you send flowers
through the books
the books
uh now you'll get six percent off with
Kudos that's basically free money
with Kudos you can buy your mom a
present and put more cash back into your
own wallet at the same time that's a
win-win what do you what are we buying
mom when is Mother's Day oh it's coming
up [__] when is that it's uh May 14th
May 14th oh [__] okay I have some time
got me freaked out over here
I had a little panic attack thanks kudos
um the best thing about Kudos is it's so
easy to use
you add kudos to your desktop or your
iPhone and a few clicks
shop like normal and Kudos will
automatically appear at checkout to
handle the rest
for example I was at booking.com the
other day
I wasn't at booking.com I can't lie to
you guys
I wasn't
okay let's say if you were I was
shopping at booking.com the other day
and Kudos not only helped me get the
most rewards but also reminded me
about other hidden card benefits like
baggage protection oh so that is it's
nice but like I did I wouldn't do it
people not people know I'm not traveling
anywhere where am I going booking.com
right you might travel and that's great
so go to booking.com with Kudos and then
you'll get hidden benefits he'll sell
you like baggage protection
what is baggage protection like if it
just Falls it just disappears they gotta
pay you or something
gets lost I don't know
that could be a good benefit to you
everybody's bag great benefit it's a
no-brainer guys in fact Kudos has saved
the average user over 750 dollars per
year what the fridge that's like a round
trip ticket to Europe
for a limited time only one person who
signs up for Kudos which once again is
free will win a 50 gift card to Teddy
fresh
oh
how much is that I
know that's cool so don't wait use the
code after dark to double your rewards
and get kudos for free by going to Joint
kudos.com slash after dark that's join
kudos.com after dark so they know uh
that we sent you yeah try it out it's
it's a
it's an amazing service I mean let's get
saving y'all it's free indices and they
sponsor us so
kudos to you
I'm a man of the people I just can't lie
about I know he's never been to
american.com you know
if I don't have my if I don't have
my I don't even say Integrity but if I'm
not honest then what am I
well it's also just kind of pointless to
I don't think I think it you could just
read it that away and it's just that's
powerful to me it's just always funny
when they like put words in my mouth and
anyone who watches the show is like yeah
because like I don't you know what I
mean you know me but uh anyway next up
thank you to
the gracious the ever powerful honey
honey now here's one that I love
today's episode is sponsored by Honey
PayPal honey that is the easy way to
save When shopping on your iPhone or
computer boom I'm not even kidding how
much money has honey saved us this one
this one is from this week from me this
one's new yeah what'd you get I bought
some shoes and this website they were
having a like a new discount that I
didn't know about so it was on the
website but I didn't know about it
usually they don't so I didn't pay
attention dude that's freaking and then
honey was like yo 135 yeah that's it I
can't I can't even front plenty is
insane I have it on all my computers all
these guys do too I think uh what it
does is it manually search for coupon
codes so you don't have to stress about
it you know honey is free shopping till
the sky was the internet for promo codes
and implies the best one you find
automatically to your cart imagine close
your eyes
you're shopping at one of your favorite
sites
then you click checkout
and the Honey button appears and all you
have to do is click the magical button
apply coupon
a wave of euphoria rushes through your
body wait a few seconds as honey
searches for the coupon that it finds
for that site and just like magic an
orgasm
you'll watch the price drop Magic
it is beautiful when that happens it's
like wow I was productive today and talk
something I'm talking clothes tech
gadgets food pizza
all working with honey yeah
so honey doesn't just work on the
desktop now either it works on your
iPhone too just activate it on Safari on
your phone and save on the go
if you don't already have honey you are
gonna be straight up missing out
on a massive savings and by getting it
you'll be doing yourself a solid and
supporting this show thank you get paid
pal honey for free at joinhoney.com
after dark that's joinhoney.com after
dark thank you so much to our wonderful
sponsors please consider uh supporting
them thank you
thank you yo two times Twisted donated
five bucks he says this Dono is from
money I just got from sunny
[Applause]
and me the money you save on honey
love that all right so there it is now
that uh We've thanked our sponsors and
uh
warmed up a little bit I think it's time
it's time to play the annual second
annual guess who is hi brother
we need more heat
yes I wrote this joint up in the morning
then I smoke it up I don't know if you
can do that
I've gotten away with it so high
this might not age well
okay listen it's a Jamaican accent wheat
is part of their culture and their
religion
I can't do a German accent I'm sorry I'm
just loving it might not age well well
you might be right you might be right
you know but what's the difference
between a Jamaican accent and a German
accent or an English accent what's the
difference
[Music]
people can't do Chinese accent right you
can't imitate somebody with Chinese
accent that's that usually don't come
off that no that doesn't come off
they've had they've had a lot of
different histories
so I feel like
people get more offended about is there
a hit okay yes is there a history of
like counting fathers walking around
doing Jamaican accents
okay all right
[Music]
yeah you can't do the Chinese one that's
true
I wouldn't even do it now as a joke
um I wouldn't even do it right
you know what I mean let's do a poll
let's do a ball can you do the Jamaican
accent
yeah I would like to know I would like
to know
yeah I mean Chet's been getting away
with it
no and that's no no he hasn't and in
fact all of this started because you
were criticizing him for doing that and
saying he was insane for I'm doing a bit
he's walking around he was doing the bid
too no stop it's literally the same
thing no it's not the bit that he's
doing is questionable but I guess you
could argue that it's a bit
but it's questionable
joking
I think I can do the Jamaican accent
we gotta ask the Jamaicans did you mean
is there any Jamaicans in the audience
no I've already guessed me
vote Yes brother
let's fire up the joints oh
cause the morning sun goes up and the
joint goes up
and the afternoon sun goes up and the
that's 51 says yes although 49 is pretty
staggering amount of note
you know
I'm sorry
I Feel Like You Gotta Give me something
you know what I mean
regardless let's move on
yeah
right into it yeah so much to do so
little time guess who's high so uh at
this point I believe you all are gonna
step away okay
as a constant Jamaican viewer don't push
Ethan oh [__]
I got the don't push from a Jamaican
prove you're Jamaican send us your idea
hold it
[Music]
all right so y'all are gonna step away
yes
some will smoke some will not maybe none
will smoke maybe all will smoke yeah
maybe how do we guess
because last time they came and sat with
you right were you here last time I was
not so they're gonna each take turns
going up to the podium okay well we'll
have an opportunity to interview them
okay and make a determination all right
so guys please go up go excuse
yourselves and come back lady for break
twenty
all right
all right the crew is uh getting up
where are you guys going in the alley or
the front
Hot Box the bathroom
what for real okay let's go They're
gonna go Hot Box the bathroom
uh don't use the one on the right
I'm just kidding I'm just kidding I'm
just kidding
wow
huh
you know I have this I don't know why
this is happening but I keep clogging
the toilets did you hear about this uh
yeah I don't know what
why is that happening is it still
happening well I had a I had a close
call yesterday really it looked like a
clogger but it went down look thankfully
and because I thought that you said that
you weren't pooping as much recently so
well I think that's part of the issue
you know
because I've been I've been on a crazy
diet you guys I've been on like a
thousand calories a day or something in
the past couple weeks
so I don't know I'm actually the the
lightest I've been since starting this
journey from my Max I'm at like two
to
18. okay
that's good
it's so hard though it takes so long
so hard to eat a thousand calories a day
oh my God
or maybe like definitely people are
going to say don't do it yeah a thousand
sounds insane it's under 1500 I'd say
but that's just what it is man you gotta
you gotta do it
I want to lose the [__] weight I'm so
tired of being [__] fat well you're
doing good thank you
still see the difference like it's still
happening
I haven't got much like um
looking skinny yet like before
everyone's like yo you're looking so
we'll see once it starts becoming more
visible
love are you potentially going to be
smoking weed no of course not that's
super illegal there right yeah I would
never smoke a Sweden the swedes are so
uptight about drugs
yeah it's kind of weird uh I I mean I
see more movement towards
being pro
drugs but it's slow very slow
so what happens if you get caught with
like a joint
probably are fine just a fine yeah but
if you're carrying to distribute or
something like that you're [__] like
how [__]
jail well carrying distribute usually
means you've got like a certain amount
with baggies or a scale or something
yeah I mean a certain amount of blunts
could probably be considered
distribution
um
not scary
yeah
brother you can't just light up a joint
man what kind of country is this
for you
and last time it was alcohol too so this
time they're not doing that so we
excluded the crossfaded category okay I
felt it was just a little too confusing
okay like you you know what I mean yeah
it's a little too tall of an order
so we're keeping it strictly to weed
yeah
that's right
mm-hmm
so uh
yeah I don't know it's been hard this
this diet's hard I'm not gonna lie about
it have you still been doing the
treadmill
I do I don't do it every day but I do it
like a couple or a few times a week
you know yeah
so
that's what it is
see what else we got here
this guy is so CR I don't want to say
creepy because I don't want to be mean
about it but
there's this 48 year old Tech
billionaire
and he's doing like he's trying to stop
aging
huh
and his whole journey like his face
looks
uncanny
like he gets lasers and he takes
supplements and he does all this crazy
[__] oh you can't switch right you guys
can't see what I'm showing oh but his
skin is almost like uncanny valley Abe's
lit I can tell
all right everyone's coming back in
Olivia looks lit dude I think Shredder's
lit always Shredder in there with you
guys you tried to charge the door you're
like no no no no yeah
oh
all right oh I getting a
perhaps a smell a waft of marijuana now
let me ask some questions up front
what was the method of consumption did
it vary per person or was it all the
same method
everyone who partook hit a big fat blunt
there was a fat blunt that got passed
around yes indeed like a [__] cigar
how big was it can you show me pretty
bad you want to go get it oh yeah I'd
love to see it all right maybe don't
show it we'll keep it yeah just show me
so let me get a look at these guys
everyone is Zach's or Lou's not back is
he
I think you just went to the bathroom oh
I smell it now now everybody went did
Lena go
we wanted everyone to go just oh you
didn't even finish it how long was it
originally
okay so I'm assuming you you
masterminded that Dan
showed me like a three inch long uh no
um
Sam was the one that went and uh got all
the stuff you roll that Sam or did you
buy it no I bought it they sell like
pre-roll points now it's crazy we're in
the future I I was just gonna say the
times man me and you Dan we've been
around
times are so different
buying a pre-rolled blunt I got these
other ones but no one wanted to hit them
for some reason I'm I'll take one home
Just Dance it's possible it could get me
so high if I chose to party can I show
the package
I just I just won't what is it
um they were infused and I didn't know
like what that meant but apparently they
were like rolled and then dipped in oil
then yeah it was like a hole and it has
hash crumble in it too yeah it says it
says 1200 milligrams of THC
isn't like five what's in a normal gummy
that's enough to time travel I think
all right well let's just get started so
is everyone back I think everyone's back
yeah now participants include Lena
is that right
was Lena in the bathroom with you guys
Lena did not participate okay and cam
participated so everybody but Lena yeah
all right so who do you want to talk to
First Ela to do our this uh
hmm
would you feel it that fast yeah yeah
we'd yeah you you feel it right I mean
we could wait five minutes probably
build up over 10 minutes yeah and just I
don't wanna
if I if I didn't want to miss the window
if I hit a joint I'd be high already
right I mean that's fair to say right
Olivia it's been a few minutes I think
it's fine it depends on the person you
know what yeah I'm I'm sorry I'm gonna
spoil it just mine are you I did not
participate either just because is Aid
and I don't want to get supplied for
that so amelina did not respect okay
we're off which it was last year too
yeah unfortunately oh really so it it it
it does move but it doesn't move fast
like it's on 420 or around it and will
be for a while you can't smoke during
Ramadan you're not supposed to smoke at
all but like really I don't know a lot
of Arabs we are Muslims yeah we're like
we feel extra guilty yeah yeah okay he's
watching extra yeah God Is Watching
extra clothes on this day all right so
let's get started here let me talk first
to Olivia
I'm getting high vibes
hello
hello come on up Olivia is coming up to
the stand Now where's the faces here uh
where I'm gonna they're on your desk
right in front of you okay and actually
here I'll come position it between here
I have the
here I've got the faces Hello Olivia
hello
and then um
Sam can you send out the lie detector to
hook up Olivia too
okay
so here we go well we know unfortunately
Lena and ABR
ah silver as a gopher
there's more than three of you left
though isn't it
yeah there's a whole line
[Applause]
all right Olivia
now I noticed when you came out from the
bathroom yeah
you had made a comment
that Dan had offered you to hit the
super blunt well last night when Sam had
sent in the chat what she was buying she
said is a thousand milligrams a lot and
I was like yeah that's great that's like
a lot of them I'm pretty sure and Dan
responded in chat that even if he or I
had hit that it might get us both very
very high
okay was it presented to you in the
bathroom it was shown to me yeah it was
really pretty I said that I was going to
take one home you didn't take one home
yeah so you do smoke regularly I do how
frequently do you smoke
at least a few times a week okay so
you're a seasoned vet
do you find that you're somebody who can
handle being high well in public
um
the anxiety that happens sometimes when
I'm high what's five plus eleven it's um
five plus eleven is 26.
it's 16. I got it right
you're way off
yeah
I mean give me times tables I'm better
at times tables all right below 12. so
what do we think I mean do we keep going
or should we get say hi yeah
I gotta I mean we could keep asking but
give me times tables let me remind you
that we will not believe it until the
end it was the shot it was the shock the
shock of me getting it wrong yeah I was
shocked what's three plus eleven
three plus eleven is 14.
[Applause]
I keep saying multiplication is my game
but what's 20 times five but that's not
fair I said below 12. 20 times five
twenty times five I'm not gonna play
this game
dude you're so high 120.
laughs
a hundred Ethan it's a hundred Ethan
it's not 120. it's a hundred by the way
20 times 5 is 100. so who's losing right
now you remember
100.
hi he's definitely High people he's high
got him ladies and gentlemen we
go well I think we can call it a view of
five yeah okay thank you for your
service we'll see we'll see she's litty
let's see so work saying Olivia is
the tape Olivia is
High
[Music]
hey I feel confident in that one yeah me
too
I feel good
okay who's next hmm then you wanna do
Dan already
no Dan is like the final boss of this
game
hey
we can take it Lou let's do Lou all
right Lou get up here
Loop
Louis
[Applause]
whoa baby
Here Comes Lou and the Goat shirt
hello everyone walking briskly I noticed
you usually walk briskly yeah wait wait
basically fat quickly
long legs right
right [__] what's up uh speaking to the
mic uh I am Ian thank you very much
I'll turn them up
what's up dude
what's what's up
[Laughter]
he's high really I'm testing him all
right I want to make it okay so from
that I was getting he's not high really
yeah I do Laugh A House Divided cannot
stand
okay let me ask you this yeah if Lou is
high is that high
yeah
yeah they're both not yeah
yeah what's the difference between Lou
and Zach
like I said last year I I feel like
that's a uh I gave you this answer I
feel like that's a subjective question
well it's you it's subjective to who I
mean you're the guy you're the Luke what
is your answer yeah subjective okay
subjective it's you I'm asking
no it's Lou means something different to
everyone yeah oh so everybody has a Lou
I guess it's like your alter ego
it's just more like their impression
like everyone takes something a little
bit different away when they speak to
Luke
sometimes they're inspired sometimes is
Lou a good guy [__] yeah he's the best
dude I thought the like a fox he Fox
yeah Fox dude [__] that is Lou does Lou
like Legos of course who doesn't like
Legos [__] wrong with you if you don't
I'm getting the vibe that uh Zach and
Lou are not that different
you got it all figured out don't you
just have a lot in common got it all
figured out don't you
[Music]
last time what really got it is that
because the alcohol right it was like
sorry yeah
the old drinky poo yes yeah that's a
different vibe
Dan ask him something about his like
keyboard I don't know
ask him something about his keyboard
about
sound effects
what's your favorite key
B okay and why is that what's eight
times four I'm not gonna go down that
road
I I'll sober or whatever hi sober I'm
not I'm not doing math eight times four
eight times eight four uh 48.
32. almost 10.
he's in my opinion hi I'm
China but I'll say laughter I actually
last year there was no question I yeah
but last year my guesses were not 100
accurate actually far from it
all right
anything else
I'm not done with you
um
people are saying not people one person
saying he's drunk for sure no there's no
alcohol I wish there was that curveball
but no
well
um let's do a poll yeah
can we use one of our Lifeline lifelines
this is not going to sway my opinion I'm
pretty sure I know the answer but I'm
just curious what the people on defense
I feel like it could be sober
nah I'm on Loop this guy doesn't know 30
this guy doesn't know well dude I fixed
the blue I don't know
86 percent or 80 66 percent now 62 okay
there's some movement 60 okay
it's changing rapidly sixty percent say
you are high Zach
do you feel like everyone's watching you
everyone's always Watching Me 1984
exists do you feel like this
conversation has been short
I feel like that's a subjective question
all right get out of here
thank you thank you very much
I'm on the fence but I'll I'll follow
you because I'm on the fence
there's something about when I was
staring him yeah over a long time yeah
I sensed
something off
[Laughter]
all right what do we got okay so hey
let's see we did
Olivia's Act
Cameron I mean what am I supposed to
take away from this dude I'm sure
yeah oh Cam come on down all right
coming down
give it up for camera folks
look at that suit
wow Here Comes cam wow wait are those
like are those like business procs fill
this up put those up business that's a
great outfit I don't know what business
they would be but hold on
they're like slim fitted I'm wearing my
uh suit with my tie-dye Crocs today
at last what's the occasion guess who's
High
and why did you think that
it was necessary to put on a suit today
I thought it might throw you off a
little bit throw me out there or not I'm
high throw me off and what about the
suit would throw me off it's
professional with straight lace you know
I feel like
businessy
right doing business doing business
stare at me
foreign
I
smile all the time
you smile all the time is that right I
think so would you smell the guy
you're very good at making eye contact
thank you
thanks yeah when's the first time you
heard you had a beautiful voice
recall actually I don't know
I think I have a beautiful voice that
means a lot thank you very much
you know you have a you you know you
have a beautiful it's all right I feel
like it's overrated to be honest with
you
um
tell me uh I think it's over as a gopher
you think so I don't know there's a
heaviness in his eyelids
anything you say would be so funny if
they are sober because you're like
there's a heaviness in this eyelids but
I feel like I can see it I can see it
it's right there are you hungry cam I
mean come on always hungry what do you
like more like are you hungry or do you
just like free food
foreign
I think it's a Pavlov's Bell type
situation where I hear this free food I
become hungry you become hungry yeah
right yeah smart I don't think I'm
hungry until the prospect of free food
comes into the picture because you know
do you see what Amy brought
uh I did not yet see it oh it's crazy
back there I cannot wait for that bro I
got a vegetarian meal just for you Kim
thank you very much
treating us too kindly
hmm
what do you what is what's the read on
this one uh
so hard if he was an embryo what would
he be raising I feel like he would be
more like not making eye contact with me
if it was high
no no but that's part of it when you get
high sometimes you just like
stare
you get lost in space
I mean but I feel like if you're high
you get a little nervous you don't want
a guy contact with people right you guys
are my mind
right now yeah but cam you're an
experienced smoker you smoke regularly
right I'd say so yeah a few times a week
once or twice a week
once or twice a week yeah and
so how much did you smoke today
I can't reveal that information I mean
you tried these tricks the last time
they didn't work and and when's the last
time you spoke
pleading the fifth for the sake of the
game what reason would you have not to
smoke if you're a smoker
not to smoke yeah you gotta go to work
you gotta drive you gotta do all sorts
of things that you gotta stay straight
laced for I guess you wouldn't you can't
do it high like as a steady smoker I
didn't say that but do you come to work
however
you could be honest okay be honest
sometimes yeah sometimes you feel it
impairs your job
um it's more on the off days when
there's less going on like on a Tuesday
when I was doing prep stuff I don't
think yeah no I've never been high as
far as I can remember during the show
outside of you ever smoked at work
uh in the parking lot but
in the morning
ever smoke in the bathroom
um yo plead the fifth again bro I'll
plead the fifth again excuse me my
attorney my attorney uh
I don't recall him asking for an
attorney
again so I'm having a problem here I
don't know if this will happen last time
I think everybody's high right I think
Cam's hot
he's not
A House Divided cannot stand in the
words of Lou it's subjective the um I I
threw up a poll right as we started this
time okay and it's very divided uh
though it is leaning no at the moment
really it's 52 yes or no it must be the
suit that sways it into the nose yeah
the suit helps Kim what's
tell me
kind of like what's your favorite tool
to use in Photoshop what's like the
coolest tool
can't pick one over the other just
describe one to me that you like I like
the lasso tool you know you can helps me
uh select things with more refinement go
on
um has there been any cool update to
photoshop lately I'm sorry has there
been any cool update to photoshop lately
what's five times seven hundred minus
50. dude if you're asking me I'm gonna
plead the fifth on math as well
I went to school this is not pictures
you have no constitutional rights in
this building grow up and solve its own
problem that's what I gotta say that's
my result well that's why we have chat
GPT exactly what does chat TPT think
okay
this is hard like with Cam and dance the
same way because like you just never
know
so I didn't get an answer has there been
any cool update to photoshop
not that I can really remember the last
one I really liked was the content aware
fill which helped blend stuff remove
stuff from the background and okay make
it better I don't know but recently I
can't really
speak to that
oh brother I feel like a politician up
at the podium right on the fence but I'm
gonna say he's high I just I want to say
really I still think he's sober the the
majority has no 53 I'm sober you gotta
follow my walk a
straight line
it's not drunk yeah well listen I'm do I
have my methods and uh
he's fidgeting with the mic no it's it's
falling
turn around
and one foot
very impressive that's pretty good
do jumping jacks
crisscross
there we go wow I'll put a leg in the
middle
can you do it where you jump over your
own leg
bro's getting started dude
the people are saying no but I think yes
so
this is my this is a problem we gotta
make a call we got a lot more people to
get through Follow My Lead okay so Ela
I'm gonna take her lead Cameron
okay
Ethan we gotta keep it moving man I got
cold food's getting cold yeah food's
getting cold
all right
I think he's high dude
all right you guys got me this man this
this dude's high as [__] right now dude
we'll see we'll find out we'll find out
soon
all right Amy we could have done it
first could he could it be that he got
you to move I'm just trying to get this
move along now could you be getting less
awkward if he's high
less awkward if he's high
I think someone who smokes regularly
uh yeah I I don't wouldn't say less
awkward but
just really hard to tell the difference
I haven't smoked in years but when I did
I was a lot smoother when I was high I
feel like really I feel like I was a lot
more anxious yeah all right Sam get up
here and then it just completely flipped
who is Sam float on over here
look at that she's so freaking high
right now
he doesn't even know where she's walking
she's going crisscrossing
that's why cam was having problems
keying out pretty hard blue and green
it's kind of sick though yeah
like a snake skin you keep it on her
yes
laughs
you know what I'm gonna say yeah I know
Sam no Sam had a lot of work this
morning so maybe it would have been nice
to kind of like say okay I'm done
let's have a little step of this joint
hey Sam
who is who is Sam can you answer that
Sam I am
you are Sam
bars
but on on a more metaphysical level tell
me like who are you as a person
everyone else got way easier questions
what's wrong with that
I don't know I'm just I'm just me
and what does that mean exactly
um
what's five times six thirty okay gotcha
okay what's seven times four uh 21.
[Music]
that was seven times three yeah but I
misheard if you chose one word to
describe Sam what word would you choose
one word to describe myself
uh I don't know what about maybe
creative okay okay creative
[Applause]
Sam
do I smoke regularly yeah no no
absolutely not what's the last time you
smoked
um you don't have to answer that
question
the fifth what's the problem day not a
trick question when's the last time you
smoked how long ago was it guess who's
High last year really oh wow really is
that right yeah oh wow and why is it you
don't smoke more often makes me very
paranoid
you know the incident
yes if that was uh traumatic for you the
song yeah this is very traumatic
I vote Yes I think she's high too okay
but you know but uh
the poll uh from the chat is 88 yes
okay if you think that that's fine why
do you think that 87 of the participants
in this poll think you're high
I don't know because they're in a silly
goofy mood they're in a silly good food
they're just they're I don't know I
think they just they want me to be high
all right goofy balls yeah what do you
like to do when you're high you like to
smash you like to watch stuff I don't
know I never am high
so what are you gonna do then
if I were to be high I would eat you
would eat something yeah you excited for
ab's food I am I've been nibbling on it
20 minutes yo wait what were you eating
I've been sneaking chicken and it's so
good here I want some chicken it's so
good let's get let's get a move on
it's gonna be great I think she's High
okay thank you
you're welcome
Let's see we got a b e and oh no ab and
Lena are not sure uh Ian Ian
sober as a gopher nope
we had a fasting for Ramadan section
last year oh yeah right
ever told on a brother nope let's not go
there
I have a brand new better down when
you're down on the luck yup
oh
was the [__] tight nope
was it
uh
was it right nope was the [__] tight
are you asking again Star Wars no Ian
thoughts Yoda yeah
dinner how did you guys decide who would
smoke and who wouldn't
uh it was sort of just in the moment
people were feeling yes or no there was
kind of went around we didn't
pre-determine it so there's volunteers
yeah and there was there certain people
were like I don't want to smoke today
yeah yeah I think I could say that yeah
and I'll ask you do you smoke regularly
no no
no I'm with Sam on that one we we do not
smoke in our in our house that's good
what do you guys do do you guys do any
drugs recreationally the two of you guys
no I mean we eat a lot of like brisket
brisket that's pretty good that's fire
yeah does Sam make brisket no
bledsoes oh bloody you know we were we
ordered there for so many times we had
to like chill we had to take a break
yeah we we have that problem they're
vegans some of the
yeah like it's too much it's all fat
it's just a big piece of fat it's sober
as a gopher by the way I think he's
sober too yeah
but yeah but I'm just enjoying talking
me about them yeah you ever get like the
high fat uh brisket there's like the
high fat and like the lean brisket I
think we always get high fat dude it's
crazy though it's like and then you dunk
it in the barbecue just a big fat piece
of barbecue
good
what is your shirt today the Kacey
Musgraves
[Music]
he's a country pop singer oh you've I
mean he's got to be sober right yeah
sober yeah
are we locking in yeah let's lock it in
thank you okay
and finally the final boss damn boss
are people just eating back there is
that what this is not fair
oh thank you oh my god really this is
not fair I want food now
nope I'm here Daniel are you hungry yup
dinner oh that's what he goes he goes
hungry nope
dinner yeah
is this your great line that is me
last year you were high
indeed both times that we did it
remember we did this is our third time
well so we did the one where we
introduced the drinking as an element
right but then we had done it on 420 and
that was just smoking that was the
original so yeah we've done it twice
both times I was high and in fact both
times you thought I was sober because
that it's just not right it's not fair
but it would make sense that Dan would
try to double cross me this year and go
so would we actual sober
now you have continued to regularly
smoke weed since the last time right
yeah you know how many times a month a
week
two to three
does Ali participate no she can't
she doesn't yeah interesting she's on a
med that well
would interact with it I feel that yeah
and what's your favorite snack when
you're high
I mean the obvious answer is the chips
and I do like chips but I don't know
probably ice cream actually oh [__]
that's dangerous yeah yeah people are
saying he's high but chocolate mocha you
know colored cream what's your favorite
flavor flavors uh chocolate chip cookie
dough okay
yeah that gave me high right now yep
people know people know
um
Dan do you ever come to work hi
uh
Tuesdays when we don't have shows
sometimes oh so Tuesdays the 4 20 of us
because you know I don't like to be high
when we do the show but if it's a dark
day then you know and I'm always that's
my day to do emails and office work and
stuff and yeah what kind of emails do
you do
well with like the sponsor stuff or I
don't know everybody everybody knows my
email address so I get a lot of uh email
from the fans thank you so much for all
that
um I think I don't know I think yeah I
think yeah
um
but I want to say a band
do you smoke before you come to work or
at work
like
before don't incriminate yourself Dan
you go out into the parking lot then you
talk up we're just in my car before I
come in you know in your car we gotta
start scheduling this then yeah yeah you
blazing your car by yourself that's so
degenerate well I don't uh not flower
like a little I have like a vape pen
okay okay yeah that's all I really do
anymore
that's the vape pen you'd prefer to vape
yeah I mean it's theoretically not as
bad on your what'd you say 40 times
seven
40 times seven
that's it
it's a tricky one forty times seven
not particularly uh 280 yeah
anyway well the interest of of eating
I'm gonna say well I I feel confident
that Dan is high okay we agree the only
one we've been split on is
but the first one I already followed
yearly you said Olivia Olivia so
yeah I thought we agreed on that though
we did yeah and that's everybody that's
it yeah thank you guys
I got last time we were drinking I knew
we find out they're gonna reveal now to
us oh Alfredo's sweet boy cute
last time we did a a segment we were
drinking I got an email from HR they're
like uh please don't encourage people to
drink on she was kidding but I was like
what
all right so let's just start let's go
in order uh when it comes to the case of
Olivia
mm-hmm
if you can't say this in a Jamaican
accent in the Throne of reggaeton
Olivia are you high
yes yeah
you did an incredible job
that's the right questions all right I'm
feeling good so far though all right
next up was was it Zachary Lou
if you can't say in a Jamaican accent
Zach Bernstein are you high I'm not high
oh no
sorry
oops was that the one we disagreed on no
it was just it was only a cam
I'm high I'm high on lube and I'm not
high on Wheels
yeah I'm sober as a gopher
D damn
you really [__] yeah I [__] with you
so I'm a good actor the show is game is
so hard
okay
the case of Sam
I'll just go down the line okay
Sam
for sale Mayo for Sam of Georgia
are you high
no oh my God oh God big time
what the hell
are you guys like trying to act high or
were you just being normal
what I I was a Sam seemed Stone Cold
Sober to me delicious wood because
you're high as [__] all right
Tim were you trying to act high or were
you just being totally normal no I was
being normal
but I wasn't the only everyone thought
Sam was hot it was like 80 percent yeah
Mayo for Sam God damn
that's a bar Mayo for Sam God damn
it's always high
but sober as a gopher
all right so once again I'm failing
uh damn are you [__] high right now
Dan this word
Dan this word love love I'm gonna get
this word bird
I'm gonna get you this I am high you got
me oh yeah
yeah now here's the thing I was trying
to mind game you but you didn't you
didn't take the bait okay because well
because I wasn't operating on the high
level that you are now listen because
the last few years
I was trying to uh seem sober and it
worked this year I was high but I
decided to just lean into it thinking
that you would think I was [__] with
you but you didn't even go there you
were just like nah you're high right I
think you're
potentially overthinking this because
you're hot into what the president
you know but I'm glad we got you this
time yeah
we got one all right well actually we
got two two
these are risky ones because here we
have ham and Ian who are sober and I
feel like we've we've already got two
sobers here so I'm not feeling super
confident about these two but with that
being said Cameron in the suit
he came out looking preppy
to
mislead us
did it work Cameron are you high or
sober I'm very stoned right now
got him
you almost got me at the end there I was
giggling when we were making eye contact
I I knew it I knew your ass was hot yeah
trust your gut buddy I was staring at
him this is my killer move you stare at
them but I was doing good the first half
I was gonna go there it's so awkward to
just stare at them but that's why I was
like it wasn't awkward oh it was I could
tell
not for you you weren't in the stair I
didn't feel awkward no there was
something there
all right I don't know better luck next
year
how much do you guys smoke who's the
highest one right now
Olivia smokes about the same amount
right
some more than others I think I guess
maybe a little more yeah all right well
and again yeah and the final count here
Ian
Ian Slater
uh I am high yeah
[Applause]
you were like
cold cold and especially considering you
don't ever smoke are you like really
high how high are we I I don't know I
try I I tried to do a double but I will
be honest I was very nervous when you
were questioning me I could not tell you
were the most sober person up there man
yeah I don't know maybe I didn't smoke
enough but I think I did [__] no you he
had what you hit it like three times
yeah two times yeah well you're feeling
it right a little I'm feeling a little
on edge okay so maybe you did smoking
though
is that possible
I don't know normally the last two times
I've come over there I've I've been fine
but this time I was like oh he's gonna
ask me some stuff [__] it was getting to
me a little bit which question made you
most nervous
the the anticipation of how you're going
to look into my soul you know yeah you
were so sober dude
oh well once again this year I'm another
failure
I swear next year we got to do like
who's on ketamine or something more okay
more obvious you know well before we
move on
of you
thought about me
are you
when did you smoke
oh
no you're not high you're not no no
you wanna ask me questions wait what is
happening right now
you were sitting here with me the whole
time when they went to smoke we were
sitting here together the whole time
yeah
so no I don't want to ask you questions
your final answer
I'd be [__] mind Gap if you're high
right now
[Laughter]
you want to ask her a question you want
to ask me a question no I have a she
didn't just say yes or no did she no
well I think she are you I
what's your final answer I was gonna say
well I think I was gonna say no but like
what the [__] is happening right now
I'm saying
I'm
your speechless speechless
[Laughter]
I'm running through the events in my
mind like uh when you finally get the
answer at the end of a whodunit and you
look back on all the clues where were
all the clues
they went to the bathroom you stayed
here yeah
did you
go before they went
also you are participating in this
segment you seem fine
all right I mean I feel like rationally
I have to say no
although you got that's what Ken said no
you're not high
you're not high I'm high what the [__]
[Applause]
what the [__] is happening
what and maybe I'm high and I don't even
know it what is happening right now when
did this happen Hilo
I went to the bathroom before the
sponsors and then when this before
You've Been High that long yeah when you
started doing the sponsors and you
talked about Shopify that's when I
started filling it and I was like oh my
God
I thought maybe you were just you know
on the spot I didn't think into it but
sometimes you know I put you on the spot
what the [__] is happening did you smoke
a joint what did you do
um they have a pen who's been scheming
on this who got my Wi-Fi nobody did it
so I didn't want to say anything but
when we went in the bathroom there's
like a little uh the pen was in there
and uh I did happen to notice there was
red lipstick on it wait Did you they
didn't know that you were high I got
blamed I
we were we didn't know I I just saw that
and I had my suspicions so I'll tell you
my secrets
I'm mind-blown
that's awesome do you want to go to the
bathroom uh Ethan crazier twist than the
fifth The Sixth Sense
are you alive
she is Jesus Christ what are you
how are you feeling
I feel fine
just a little
are you hungry you ready I am ready to
eat good I'm ready oh my god
oh [__] and are you like really high
I think
I took like two two poofs two poops yeah
two boobs two boobs That's crazy dude I
am mind blown
okay
you've got me that was a Twist I think
every time I had to stare at them I felt
so awkward and I was like why do they
seem so normal right now
they I don't think anyone saw that
coming man
next year I gotta be high or something
and everybody's sober
that'd be a mind [__]
I gotta know who how did this what's the
logistics here
who did this was it Sam
who did what I want to know who she went
there did you just go and see the panda
that corrupted his wife no there was a
plan there was a plan but Dan you didn't
know about it I was not in on the planet
I was not in on this plan you don't need
to see the making of the sausage okay I
know you like it but I love sausage
all right well wow what an eventful uh
fantastic segment we've had here yeah it
was twists
turns surprises shocking revelations
guess who's high and now let's move on
and on to uh the other big segment
listen The Big Show the biggest segment
some would say the biggest Brendan
Schaub the big
so okay now that that's out of the way
and everybody's nice and toasty as you
guys know bbtv sent yours truly a
[__] fat wire
for six hundred and twenty thousand
dollars
now don't get me wrong excuse me
that's money they owed us
but in a sense
I'm treating it like uh
free money because I never thought I'd
get it you found it on the sidewalk I
found 620k in a crack yeah I didn't
dream that I would ever get that money
back and so when it did come back
we're like damn we got 620 what are we
gonna do
so many good ideas I said budget
budget optional there's no budget
and these guys all had some big Ideas we
talked about going to Disney World
there was some pushback there we talked
about uh
going to Vegas that seemed too
pedestrian
so the guys the crew have each uh
prepared a PowerPoint presentation
mm-hmm
to persuade us
on which vacation we'll choose now the
audience will vote
although
the ultimate decision is in our sole
discretion yes but I will take in the
audience's opinion
Shredder's going crazy
Shadow you can have it shredders like
ever since we had to cut them off
and he's just on the really strict
kidney diet he's like he wants normal
food so bad
um yeah lots of people want to go to
Japan I had my reservations about that
but um people think I'm upset stupid
dumb idiots dumbasses dumbasses you
really need to not read the chat right
uh so everybody has put a lot of work
into these power points they're gonna do
it one by one we're gonna start with AV
because he's got food thank you dude God
bless you for that my pleasure and uh at
the end we will vote I mean either will
come to a decision decide what are we
doing with the 620. so AB go ahead let's
get you up here first okay you know
shreddy you can't have it the more I
just was thinking about it right now I
don't know if I should go first we could
eat now oh just give me the food bro
yeah let's bring the food I feel like
mine should be mixed in yeah I'll bring
the food out though you can bring it now
actually she made you guys you because
you brought food to Avie and that makes
me very happy you can go in any you just
tell me when you want to go and you're
up
I just want to be mixed in the middle
somewhere because mine's kind of
weird so does anyone want to go first
anyone feeling like they wanna
pitch
Dan is
no like people are saying why can't
Ethan get high I hate gaming High you
guys
it's not even like an option for me I
just [__] hate being high I always
feel horrible and regret it every time
so
that's why mother flippers
technically I'm going first oh my God so
what the [__] yo let's go
let's [__] go are you kidding me yeah
yo
oh my God
wait if I'm going first though look at
this
can you guys see this
there's Falafel there's like a
uh the beef skewer chicken skewer rice
hummus
grape leaves are you freaking kidding me
okay I could go down here I see them
yeah why don't you go first yeah I'll go
first I just bought oh my God okay
I'm picking a B's and Lena's
I don't care what it is
um
oh my God bro wait you are going yeah I
am going to go what happened why'd you
change your mind uh because I think Dan
has some stuff involved with his that
can conflict with mine so
okay I did just oh my God try to flush
out my eye because my eyes bothering me
so dude I'm not crying not yet
thank you guys so much no problem
I want to do something nice since the
crew covered me while I was gone for
Creator Clash
and uh figured why not get people food
when they're high oh my God this is
amazing
this is the best episode we've ever done
is it tahina
there was supposed to be a point in the
presentation where I I'm talking about
Eric food and I go by the way we have
some it's supposed to be a big surprise
but
we were taking a little long obviously
I'll pretend surprise yeah
just factor that in when you're thinking
about
dude your final decision this is insane
you guys this is like the best spread
ever
oh my God oh my God I'm so excited today
in Arabic oh my God I can't get over it
crazy this is insane they got tahina wow
salad wow stop
I'm not worthy of this this even fair to
the other people
listen yeah
it's your fault they didn't bring food
right right
thank you guys all right go ahead baby
all right you guys ready
okay this is my travel proposal so I was
thinking we should go to Palestine in
Israel wow
[Music]
that was a joke but I want to get your
guys's attention
I wanted to start with an old-timey joke
because uh I ask that you guys keep an
open mind as we go through this and wait
till the end
decision who's playing the men in
Blackstone it's it's not supposed to be
looped
I like it thank you thank you okay I
really think we should go to my hometown
of Dearborn Michigan
wow hell yeah baby I'm staying up in
London for you okay okay
what is it
he asked is that another joke nope
I'm serious
why Dearborn well before we get into
that let's look at some facts about
Dearborn
Dearborn me and lean are from Dearborn
uh
that's true
yeah yes uh Lena and I own a house in
Dearborn so we could house everyone we
could all stay together hold on we got
this big ass budget yeah just just go
and stay with your parents
um also I can show you guys my sick-ass
collections of uh collectibles in the
basement
uh my nerd wall uh Dearborn is hometown
of Henry Ford and is at home
of uh Ford Motor Company's World
Headquarters
um people stayed up late in Dearborn uh
the businesses are open late it's a big
deal because here everything closes
early you can't get food
I don't know because they're believing
the life I think Ramadan has
like something to do with it because it
kind of messes up our schedule once a
year because we stay up late like eating
um Dearborn is home to the largest
amount of Muslims in the United States
um it also has the largest mosque in the
United States and there are so many
Muslims in Dearborn that we even serve
halal steaks in the strip club that is
not a joke that's actually a thing I
love that yeah
um yeah besides that hello Haram Stakes
we have tons of great Middle Eastern
food and this is where I was going to
bring out the food surprise we have food
baby
oh yes thank you like Oprah just gave me
a card
exactly even better um who cares about a
car I'll talk more about food later on
but while we are learning about Dearborn
I think it's important to note that the
H3 podcast is the number one podcast in
Michigan
according to this car for run ready that
we've broken before I believe it huh per
this is uh per Google searches
uh being the podcast number one in
Michigan it would mean the world to the
fans who live in Michigan if they knew
we were visiting maybe we could even do
a meet and greet but maybe the fan love
and good food isn't setting the idea uh
selling the idea so I figured let's ask
a local resident why we should go to
Dearborn and who better
[Laughter]
he's loved by the audience those are
those of the audience who know who the
hell he is he's lived in Dearborn his
whole life he's never going to leave and
Ethan he loves cousin excuse me did you
just Lake a DMV
oh it's WhatsApp
so this is genuine Tim video this is
genuine and this was very hard to get he
would not answer me so I just sent his
brother in yesterday are you serious
this is how he sleeps yep Zoom get up
listen I'm just leaving with somebody
he's an interesting dude mind you this
guy inherited millions of dollars really
yeah so I need you to tell us why the
[__] we should come to Tim what's
religion get away from me ugly kid get
away from the stairs
all right go back to sleep
like I never even heard of that I
wouldn't know where to begin when we
started college me him and his brother
all renting an apartment and he paid a
third of everything and he did not stay
there once he did not even leave
anything there whoa
yep and then the deal got a house
together he did the same thing
where does he stay at that time he was
staying with my grandmas at my grandma's
which is in the middle of uh
I don't know how else to say it's in the
middle of the hood that's where and he
just decided to live there
with his mom and my grandma cousin Tim
okay we can meet cousin Tim yep we'll
come back to him this is a longer video
but I wanted to space it out okay
because I wanted to kill the uh
I wanted to kill the vibe of the
presentation
okay but going back to food
um Dearborn has a wide variety of
authentic Arabic restaurants uh some of
my favorites hamidos habibs alamir and
uh even Pierce
is that what's his name Zach Pierce Bros
yes he visited habib's once and they
never stopped talking about it and they
framed it they put it on the wall and
there's even an article in their
American news about that is a big deal
Oh yeah double seven baby
um also we can visit my hometown butcher
okay that's a big deal yeah yeah yeah
that's right it's funny I went to his
Twitter yesterday and he has three
tweets I think he made the Twitter since
we shouted him out on the show and I
didn't even I didn't see this prior but
it said uh Hey star Kelly you could
order from us any tagged H3 podcast it's
funny that's awesome shout out Ronnie I
know Ronnie hi crew how are you how is
everyone
uh we would love to I'd love for you
guys to visit us in Michigan and I would
love to cook you some nice Arabic food
some grape leaves all different flavors
whatever you like you're welcome here
anytime wow okay Selena's mom she's
offering home cooked Middle Eastern food
can I ask you a question yeah did the
state of Michigan pay you for this I
feel like this is
sponsored by Michigan no version board
Marlena's mom yeah very sweet lady so
guys how would you convince the crew to
come to Dearborn these are my
brother-in-laws
did we try food already
yeah we did yeah they're gonna come to
Dearborn we got Tim Hortons bro we got
Timmy's bro we got tibbies okay it's
stupid but we do have Tim Hortons that
is a big deal like me Lena we we really
missed Tim Hortons I don't know if you
guys ever had it but Canadian yeah yeah
we've been there so we got food
so guys how would you so besides the
good food cousin Tim and Tim Hortons
Michigan is a beautiful summer
uh how we could spend a typical summer
day in Michigan
uh and let me just say real quick
actually when I was making this
PowerPoint I intended on break like this
slide was supposed to be four slides and
it would be a lot more extreme game but
I underestimated uh how long this would
take so I will um yeah it's sort of sped
up I just want to say that but yes we
could start the day by going to one of
the Great Lakes I love Great Lakes my
uncle has a boat that would go on it
could fit most of us uh we might have to
go in two trips
uh we can play some volleyball at the
lake and then end the night with a
beautiful bonfire where we could tell
some beautiful stories that would last a
lifetime okay
just asleep in your boat may have work
at [__] 7 30. okay all right you
bothering me for a [__] video bro I
don't know well I I just don't
understand why you're snapping I asked
you for a video they're they're doing
let me tell you the concept they're
doing they're doing a thing they're
saying they got a certain amount of
money they want to go on vacation
they're taking everybody from the
podcast everyone's saying where they're
gonna go yeah Ethan loves you the people
the fans think you're funny or some [__]
I don't know and they're like okay like
Amy's like all right let me make one
where we go to Dearborn for that
vacation so they're like all right let's
make a compelling video for why we
should go to Dearborn it's a normal it's
just a it's just a listen it's all part
of it it's all part of the joke don't
get upset right now don't listen
if you reach we're gonna have a [__]
problems
I just want go ahead who's the one
filming him yeah that's his little
brother my cousin Brendan it's funny
like my whole life is his little brother
[__] I don't know why oh it's [__] up
his name again
no his brother oh Brendan Brandon yeah
you can Brendan stand up to him
physically not not since the juice
Tim's been skinnier than me our whole
lives and then just like
I don't know after since you moved to my
grandma's in the hoodie changed but that
looks like Grandma's cooking right there
I want to say that it's kind of hard to
see on the screen but my cousin Tim
never like leaves the house in short
sleeves so his arms are super white and
his face and neck is super tan it's kind
of the audience will probably see it
better than us
um yeah he's gonna come throughout this
uh presentation
we'll see him a few more times
HD Crew I really hope you come to
Dearborn because you weren't the best
and also we can play soccer and we can
do so many fun things I really miss
Adella only now please bring them too
because Abdel is my favorite uncle and
like I love her so much and I really
hope he comes and also I love Lena so
much because she's also my favorite aunt
and I really miss them and I really want
to see them and I can have so much fun
because I've always wanted to meet the
crew so please come to Dearborn that's
my name she's full of [__] she has no
idea who you people are uh I didn't
intend on putting her in this but I I
just wanted a video of Elena's mom and
she sent this and nah she's so cute so I
figured I had to how can I say no to
that exactly
also speaking of kids Dearborn is in
need of a hero right now you're going to
use good Role Models right now 10 uh
tons of dearborn's Youth idolized people
like Jordan Peterson and Andrew Tate
Peterson is like a rock star there it's
crazy Hassan brought it up on leftovers
yeah
um
also I was going to include but I have a
chance to the whole situation with the
lgbtq books in Dearborn and how that
like was insane the town hall meeting
they were trying to get yeah right they
were trying to ban they had like LGBT
books
and it you know of course that's not
everyone there's a lot of people who are
open-minded understand but it's crazy to
see little kids like with signs it's
like go back in the closet really yeah
yeah both back from the plug up
or or take put your books back in the
closet or something yeah
um our visit to Dearborn will help
spread the word of the podcast and we
can be a good influence on the youth we
can be like Jehovah Witnesses going door
to door and spreading the good word of
the H3 podcast
yeah
anything that you want edit it out we
can edit out sorry about the Antonio sub
recording I'm trying to [__] sleep
okay and you're bothering people who my
brother
just kidding why are you getting okay
listen you're getting really upset and I
understand your position here
I just say a few things
um I love how you said you're upsetting
you're upsetting people I don't know who
the hell he's talking about his brother
his brother didn't get that line either
but also every time I feel like we get
any situations with Tim he's not playing
at all he does not play along for [__]
you can see his brother it keeps
occasionally doing this this is the temp
you never know he does this thing where
he looks away for a second then [__]
launch you
so uh this is very real it looks very
real I believe it yeah
Tim may be one of these children you can
save
Tim chose the Red Bull pill and has
become who he is today filled with rage
and hate influenced by men like Tate
is he really a tate head
not like he he seems like not even
online people like he's seen some videos
and thought he was like funny but he
doesn't know like you know everything
that's going on okay and mind you his
father was like super like he was like
left wing he was the first person on the
Wayne County uh board to hire an
African-American oh his dad is a
hardcore Lefty yeah he was yeah he was
he was a very well known man he's gone
to the White House many times met many
presidents does he hate his dad uh no he
he doesn't they uh his dad passed away
he was 95 his father yeah this is like
his fifth marriage yeah oh but he you
know these are uh he hasn't had kids
since like the 50s
um
yes this this is this is innocent Tim
before wow really yeah yeah what the
[__] this is our first year of college
on the right yeah
um
what the [__] was he always like
like
you know my friend could also asked me
once what happened to Tim I'm like what
do you mean he goes
he goes did he get an accident like what
are you talking about oh my God brain
damage yeah I'm like oh no he's always
been that way it's weird though because
he's like super smart too like look at
that on the right that's a different
person yeah what the [__]
it's like a bright young kid with this
future ahead of him he was a math genius
Matt I mean he still is
um do you think he just got like this
big inheritance and he's just like [__]
it I'm good no no it's
it's tough I mean he has a mom who is
like
my my aunt's like super Lebanese like
she came here when she was already
living in Lebanon for a few years like
20 years and then his dad was super old
I just feel like that mix of parenting
kind of had an effect on him like um and
then like you know we all go through
that stage where we're kids and we we
get told what's what we either could be
like babies about it be hateful or like
get our [__] together and he just loves
to play the victim unfortunately and um
yeah I don't know this is just I think I
could put his head on straight
maybe how old is he does he remind you
of my dad The Voice 100 yeah
I didn't want to like do offend you but
that's what I thought of media no that's
all I'm thinking when I watch him yeah
and I feel like everybody in the room is
kind of scared of him yeah that's how I
feel with my dad and like it's super
yeah everybody yeah and he was kind of
big
yeah he has a really big heart he's a
really nice guy but he uh yeah
hmm how old is he I he's eight months
older than me he's 31.
I find it interesting because apparently
he had a ton of siblings right no he has
only Brennan his brother but he has five
sisters who are like in their 60s
oh yeah oh crazy yeah holy smokes that's
a pretty unusual family Dynamic yeah
yeah I realize we're at the NAACP dinner
here too
for his uh yeah
I read this 620 000 pitch end up just
about Tim
foreign
Tim came to Brendan's house in the
middle of the night about a month ago
with like six garbage bags and he's like
yeah I need a place to stay for a little
bit
and he has money it's just uh that's Tim
probably I don't know
yeah
very interesting but Dearborn is also
rich in culture
visiting Dearborn would be a great
learning experience we can visit the
largest mosque in America but we have to
make sure that we are dressed properly
for the mosque the ladies who have to
wear the proper attire just while in the
mosque
tell you fresh callers
yeah oh yeah
I asked cam for this edit camera I don't
have to say that but I asked you to do
it what do we wear what do the guys wear
oh I got you
well
I something about Ian in this photo yeah
did this picture be badass it's like
it's like Squad
left the dude on the right if we're
going to a new place we're gonna make
new friends dude I know I love it okay
can I make some new friends
we can go to an Arab wedding people seem
to really think Arab weddings are really
cool like me and Lena had you know over
a thousand people at ours shut the [__]
yes and the reason we go to air wedding
is maybe we can find love a wife oh
okay
interesting interesting interesting yeah
he's looking for a white
but I'm just saying it might pass direct
some stuff anyway what Love's going
willing to do whatever it takes yeah
whose wedding would we go to
oh just somebody they won't know okay
you ever hungry on a Friday or Saturday
night you just go to wedding just make
sure you have a suit got it
um most importantly you can learn what
it means to be a hawk does anyone here
know what a hawk is anyone know what I'm
referring to
exactly we're already learning
oh [__] so to explain what a hawk is I
have tarek salamasi
uh former boxer
he's the one who initially trained my
cousin myth for his boxing match oh and
my dad's cousin
and he's a [__] Hawk and a good guy
well out there I don't know what a hawk
is all right Hawk is kind of what a
guido is to an Italian beef I guess the
white boy
Terror that's a hawk a hawk it's a guy
who's like a predator bro let me show
you how I do it you know he gets in the
position and he perches just back up
though don't blow my shots are you from
Dearborn especially from Dearborn are
you a male
you're a hawk is that a real thing yeah
it's a real thing so you're a hawk yeah
yeah so like the whole like Cloud Goblin
thing you guys may make fun of me for I
think that's just like the the like
aftermath of being around so many hawks
my whole life like yes
[Music]
um
but yeah I'm gonna teach you some Hawk
terminology you guys will learn it more
if you were to go but Rhett on Warren is
a popular one
which means Warren's a very busy street
rat on Warren means just to do loops
going back and forth and seeing if
there's any Honeys out there driving
around red and on Warren
hmm
convertible so convertible with a
convertible means to Hawk as a girl who
wears a scarf indoors and secretly takes
it off when she's not around her family
they call her converter
and that's a good thing that's what the
guys no um
how do the girls feel about that term I
yeah they don't they don't like it but I
mean let me ask you this is it but they
use they use it they use it too is it
neutral or is it an insult to call
someone a convertible
that was definitely a [__] insult
okay I don't think anyone ever saved
someone's face always behind their back
way baby okay okay
or in a sick bits which means a good
Muslim gal
yeah the Sid bait who's someone who
doesn't ever get in the Bikini correct
these are very important to a hawk I I I
I plan on giving a whole testimony I
mean a whole explanation of why should
the company why these are so important
I'm not gonna [__] deal with this
[__] anymore listen let's do a question
I want to know the answer really
oh [__] good your cousins
Jesus Christ at this point just to [__]
this I'm done
um why should they come here
twice huh
is this a serious pitch you may be
wondering is this a serious pitch and
the answer is yes the reason is a
serious pitch is not only is it because
I want to visit home the reason I think
this should be considered as a serious
pitch comes down to one simple word does
anyone know that word
I know it's stupid I know the idea is
stupid but have you thought of the
content it's such a stupid idea and
that's what makes it great
uh just some examples the whole City on
its own is a commentary gold mine I mean
uh Tim is one of many characters if you
think of the idubbbz documentary full
force where he went to uh free where he
went was in Michigan I'm drawn blanks
right now but that was a [__] great
documentary because it was so wild to
see even as someone in Michigan I didn't
know people up there were living like
that but um we can you know there's lots
of stuff we can meet my dad's new family
be good for Content like when my mom
called in uh I don't know if you guys
are familiar with the white boy Rick The
Notorious drug dealer from the 80s he
went was like set up by the FBI and it's
a long allegedly it's a long story but
uh for some reason him and my dad are
like best friends now so uh we can find
out why they are best friends how that
happened which is very [__]
interesting to me that my dad is always
with white boy Rick shout out
um
is that fine
[Music]
and they want to know where they should
go they got a certain amount of money
they want to spend on this vacation
Abdullah thought it'd be funny to say
Dearborn is a is a spot they should go
so we're just supposed to tell them why
they should come to Dearborn since we
live here what's the why would you
vacation in Dearborn
for that like why would they come here
they could see me okay
dude his voice
wow yep so that's good yeah I thought to
Brennan forgetting that yeah they the
one that reasons it took me so long to
start on this PowerPoint yesterday was
because I was like trying to break up a
fight between them back and forth
for hours until uh we just got to the
conclusion that Tim was just grumpy
um so why Dearborn good food breakfast
with cousin Tim content we can save
dearborn's youth we can learn how to be
a hawk we could use the rest of the
money for something else okay
now I want something I don't know if I
was clear but I would appreciate it
everybody gave me a trip estimate
like a dollar value on this kind of trip
here
because we're staying with your family
ten thousand dollars maybe ten thousand
pretty affordable that's very affordable
actually
ten thousand I'm a simple man so if you
guys want to uh
yeah I love the idea of staying with
your family using your uncle's boat
really we're saving all over the place
okay A B
and once again
thank you for this fantastic food you
and Nina thank you so nice thank you
guys delicious if anybody wants any
Falafel there's more here that's one of
the best falafel ever by the way oh nice
yeah even like not warm you know it was
really good
who's next
I'll go you have answers right come on
down
I do need to pee I haven't peed yet oh
my God just cue it up I'll be right back
all right we'll cue it up yep
and we're gonna jump in here
anyone
dead air hello hello
baby what's up take the mic on
what is it
I'm totally totally not [__] high but
I'm here right now saying what's up to
you beautiful people I hope that was
entertaining I'm sorry if it was boring
see the problem was when I was using
Lena as a test audience for the
presentation I started you know giving
it and Lena knows these people she knows
Tim and Brennan and she was cracking up
like she was in tears I was like it
didn't hit me till like 4am like it's
only leaning and I think this is funny
so I hope it was entertaining thank you
thank you he's a beast
he scares me yeah it's great dude love
him you want to hear from Arizona
hell yeah baby hell yeah baby
uh let's see here what's going on
here's some old-timey jokes oh they suck
yes sir
Oh I thought you were Lou
oh look
that's a subjective question you did say
both would be at the podium yeah so [__]
you love
you want to get hostile
no I love you bro I love you too oh
oh
we're just waiting on Ethan to uh
evacuate his bladder and accurate the
bladder
so what happened to them
to Dan yeah he was about to
what happened to me yeah I'm waiting
because mine involved food too I guess
you're all done so I could do it next
after Zach that's fine
Lou I'm doing fantastic that shirt looks
very comfortable it is very comfortable
it's a little baggy but it is very
comfortable you know every time I put a
button-up shirt on I think with Zach
approved with my bike I go lower baby I
went one lower I think since I started
since I met you you gotta rock that deep
V my guy yeah
how is Shredder doing have you I so I
think I don't know if Ethan updated but
there was like one more test where his
numbers weren't like a tiny bit
uh they went up and then they went a
tiny bit down which was good but
we still don't really know it's very
weird he seems totally fine and he's
eating well
so I don't know did he get tested for
that one disease no we're scheduling it
it's apparently like a little bit
complicated they need to get a blood
test from him like three times in one
day at different hours oh yeah so we're
gonna do that
let's see what else dude this food is
incredible I'm tripping out that was so
good
Zach hi
let's hear it where we should go
by Zach Lewis
um where we should go you guys ready I'm
ready all right let's do it now
PowerPoint doesn't have a lot of bells
and whistles I don't roll like that
that's fine it's not my vibe okay not
you know not throwing shade on anyone
but I'm just I'm to the point here yeah
where we should go
well
nowhere
curveball let's stay home
and I'm gonna tell you why
traveling is a pain in the [__] ass
hold on
do we have any real suggestions or yeah
yeah oh yeah oh yeah traveling is a pain
in the [__] ass and we all know it
right
come on I agree with you okay thank you
thank you Ethan thank you who likes
going to airport run or packing it's
just it's funny [__] sucks and I
realized I put [__] [__] in there
twice you wrote [__] [__] you're
reading that verbatim yes yes
again I'm not throwing shade to people
we want to go to Japan and other places
but yeah
no one likes the hassle right you wrote
in the F yeah you're right yeah
I like your sticking to the script thank
you
no curveballs here's my vote okay
okay we celebrate
thousand dollars is split amongst the
crew or a portion we have a kick-ass
dinner
we get dinner gotcha okay dinner another
Banner double Banner
fine dining hold on I thought you said
there was no fancy PowerPoint yeah it
got a little fancy for a second there
okay fine we hire a private chef and we
have a five course meal prepared I don't
know let's have some fun okay roll the
dice sip some wine some beef tartare
some more wine okay I don't know what
that guy's eating but sure looks good
you went off script there a little bit
yeah
I like the riffing
here are some things you will miss
because you
you are not home
the first a word from Ethan Klein okay
what the f all right that for any don't
forget why you're there don't let them
convince you or brainwash you into any
other [__] reason you're there to
make money
what does that have to do that was my
smoking just wants the money right I get
that he's using your words from
Wednesday no I can't ask you I get that
but
you gave me my Smoking Gun okay okay
okay
to hold up what's that
it holds up I mean it's more about
salary but because this is technically
but basically you're saying you don't
want to spend a minute with us no that's
not the case well that would be the that
would be the essentially the result of
the suggestion I I'm just being just one
dinner
I'm being practical
I'm being I'm very very practical here
okay I'm following along okay
you're gonna miss your bed
it's a nice comfy bed I agree everyone
loves their bed right when you go to new
places you know the gotta order pillows
yeah it's all [__] up you're right
it's just it sucks
I'm with you there you're gonna miss
your own Throne you're gonna miss your
toilet right when you go to these hotel
rooms you got fear that Something's
Gonna Come and crawl up your ass you
know who's been in that toilet before
you you don't know that you don't know
how clean it's been you'll catch [__]
I don't know we'll catch something right
it's a potential all right you're gonna
miss your own TV yeah we go to Europe or
some other place they don't got your own
news stations you know it's funny to me
that you think you need to convince
Ethan to stay at home
but Zach is it's not so much a pitch as
an anti-pitch i he's in opposition to
all ideas does not leave the house you
know that mm-hmm I'm a homebody like
yourself uh since covid traveling is
very risky you know
um
I like being home I like my job I like
going from point A to point B and maybe
throwing in a point c in there you know
maybe but you're gonna miss your own TV
personally I like channel seven they
don't got Channel 7 in Europe ABC
ABC but not ABC7 right okay easy your
local you don't yeah have your local
right Channel and your local affiliate I
know my news anchors all right that
makes sense you know you're not gonna
have that
you're gonna miss your fridge
right you you go to a hotel at the mini
bar first off it probably doesn't have
anything in it you know unless you go to
one of the high-end joints still nothing
in it yeah there's still nothing still
nothing in it but you know where your
things are like if you're gonna go for a
sodi at your house both you guys you
know where it's at right okay you could
do a blindfolded right yeah okay okay
right so since we all live in LA I just
want to give you uh
um a reminder of what you would be
missing if you didn't if we if we went
somewhere took an airplane or whatever
this
Reseda California
home of The Karate Kid filming location
let's [__] go right also Cobra kai no
mercy baby so you want to do sightseeing
or no I'm just saying you'd be missing
this you could be missing I'd be missing
being nearby
I'm a valley boy I love the valley yeah
oh yeah
right here
Olivia
hey we live in the valley we lived you
guys but I can't say that I think much
about Reseda then or no very forgettable
Junction there but it feels like home in
a sense right no not Reseda oh
come to me
real fat is that um Daniel's son's
apartment complex yeah
and also Johnny's if you're Cobra Kai
fans right right no mercy
Encino California
right I like Encino that's more homish
to me okay that's home you know you got
that one shopping center I got that CPK
there that cool ass are gonna say I I
picked up some shifts at that CPK
is that where you saw Justin Bieber no
it was at the Tarzana one yeah it was a
great toy store I went there as a kid
called Gregory's
love that toy store
Greg's probably a pedo just saying
alrighty then good name Greg go to the
toy store and that's it that is my
presentation all right thank you all
you've been a terrific crowd I want to
thank you so to to summarize
portion of the money split amongst the
crew and we stay home and we make life a
lot and we get a really nice dinner and
a really nice how much are you proposing
that we split amongst the crew be
specific now
I'll have to get back to you well in the
presentation he said all or some yeah
but that really runs the game
the full spread baby
throw out a number give me a number
I need a number attached to each one of
these
350 000 all right so it's like The Price
is Right everybody was like holding up
fingers over here
how many people is that divided by
uh there's nine crew members
I've lost track of who I don't know
anymore does that include love and Lena
and everybody yeah
so what's 350 divided by nine and that's
not including me and Eva
right not including you guys so 350
divided it'll be 11. with you Anila yeah
but don't include us in this one uh
there'll be uh 38 888 and 88 cents of
course okay which if you think about it
if we do it uh an extravagant trip it's
gonna hit that Mark that's a pretty
that's pretty good
I'm just saying
arrest my case thank you very much thank
you and repeat it my friends I'll see a
receipt of my friend
there it is all right um Zach Bernstein
or should I say blue blue
line even actually that's weird
well
all right why don't I go now does anyone
have a real one I have a real yeah it
was kind of a weird order we just did
that in because I think me and Zach are
the only ones that yeah well I thought
mine was real but I see how you could
interpret it it's not
huh
just remember though Zach
if I pay you guys out
you all got to pay fat taxes on that but
if we spend it on a vacation
I'm fine paying the tax that's uh I'll
take the hit I'm completely fine taking
that out to [__] them kids okay Dan is
passing out the
plastic oh my goodness oh I see where
this is going what Dan is serious about
this Japan pitch
are you gonna guide me through these or
is this just for my enjoyment okay just
like give it a shot why Ramen snacks now
are these is this curated by you in
something you just drink it yeah I went
down to a Little Tokyo here in LA with
Ali yesterday and we got some stuff now
these drinks have a little trick to them
that little plastic thing yeah what is
it what you want to do
here I'll do one so you see how it works
use this little plastic cup
oh
wait
wait is there a ball or something yeah
where's my ball
where whoa
I just slammed this down so there's a
little there's a little plastic thing
inside
in there yeah you take that put it on
top and then you just I just slam this
down slam it
just push it
you push it hard though don't push
the Japanese are strong
they are holding
[Music]
okay now what
are you doing
you take it out there's a blue thing
comes out no no no no
to Japan
yummy oh what's this by the way this
looks good rainbow Dango
I love this drink a little rice cake
hmm is it like a dessert yeah yum oh
Theodore would love it does anyone see
Shredder
oh good oh yeah
[Music]
feeling that mm-hmm
okay
we're ready
here we go
beautiful
wow wow
here we go now why is it I can't do the
Jamaican accent but you could come out
with all the well that was an authentic
recording I didn't that's not my voice
he just played it there's another treat
here actually that we haven't tried yet
[Music]
oh well Dan I gotta say a strong start
here all right also you took you found
us exactly you and a b Club both of us
yeah we know bring food we know you food
bring drinks no problem all right let's
start with the facts play out some facts
real quick just to get started okay one
nails are Japan has incredibly uh
incredible unique attractions and theme
parks that you can't get anywhere else
in the world right no other place like
that like a Godzilla second of all
I do someday go to Japan
Ila has been wanting to go to Japan for
years while you're listening I'm
listening and so is somebody on the
subreddit who uh sent that thank you
shout out to whoever found that guy
theme parks uh yeah
uh it's the birthplace of anime as we
know uh Ethan is a weeb and get a lot of
enjoyment out of that uh it has a
vibrant and world famous fashion scene
hell yeah very critical to this pitch
let me tell you yep
um as a rich Buddhist in Shinto uh
spiritual heritage
insanely good Cuisine hell yeah
a vibrant nightlife music scene and
karaoke bars remember that that'll come
relevant later that doesn't sell me as
much and the last fact there's literally
no downsides okay there's no downsides
that's debatable really all right let's
talk about the downsides
Ethan's reluctant to take a long trip
it's too time consuming solution we can
100 absolutely do the show on the road
and he's got it all figured out okay go
ahead you're hearing it from the
producer I'm listening
it's too far away I don't like to leave
my house you know Counterpoint it is a
two hour shorter flight than Israel
which you've done many times hold on
hold on hold on how do we do not go on
the road
with it we've talked about it yesterday
we figured it out give me a rundown Road
casters two of them already got them
yeah I mean check check we bring some
equipment we film portable equipment we
bring a camera and we do the podcast on
the road
we could do that or we could just from
like a hotel room just do a podcast and
talk about what we did that day and show
videos all that kind of stuff can we do
what if we all stay in our
and we do it in a hotel room are you
kidding me or can we do it in a
beautiful area outside sure I mean
cellular bonded
isn't it like a crazy blooming season
right now or like in May uh I think so
yes um we're talking about going in June
though yeah I mean we probably wouldn't
make that okay unfortunately but the the
yeah all the Cherry balls the cherry
blossom yeah
um also
when Ela gets pregnant okay so the
information that we learned at the
beginning of this episode kind of makes
this bullet point moot
but I was trying to make the point that
like now is your win of opportunity to
go still is it still is okay it still is
in the beginning I can still travel but
right later on okay so it's still
relevant I've got kids it makes it too
complicated that was the biggest
objection right solution money
you have a nanny who would I'm sure love
to go to Japan also or or before you say
anything alternate solution
oh
yeah you have to ask them about that
right that's up to them unfortunately
that's what grandparents are for that's
all I'm saying well I like to think so
too but sometimes they have a different
opinion about what they're doing so
should you choose to bring the kids
along which is a is an option uh through
the power of Technology there are
solutions to many common problems
traveling with the child such as uh this
product that just happened
oh my God
reasonable device to silence your baby's
cries
if you despise your John tell me that
this is real I think it's a meme
all right all right so
what am I gonna do yeah you're in Japan
first of all let's talk about the
fashion scene yeah because Ela needs to
see this [__] yes okay there's this area
in Tokyo Hara
okay so all these it's like the street
fashion Mecca basically and everybody's
hanging out there and showing off their
looks and everything and it's got a
whole scene it's a hub for youth culture
and fashion it's famous for its uh
eclectic Street Styles quirky
subcultures
um you're right and then there's this
street to kashita Street sorry if I'm
saying that wrong uh which I believe I
have yeah a little video here
just show what it's like so these are
like all vintage shops fashion shops
it's just like just crazy an epicenter
for it basically
um
Dan how long do you believe we would
need for this trip right do it well
right week week and a half
I mean if we're just doing Tokyo
obviously there's more going on in Japan
but I was trying to keep it within the
constraints of like we take a trip to
what's your okay what's your ideal
amount of time
the ideal amount of time on
I mean realistically since we're talking
about like a two-week window I feel like
a week and a half or so with some travel
ten days on either side makes sense can
I ask would this conflict with our other
break
this will be during our break it will be
during that break
hypothetically I mean I don't know
that that's to be well if it's during
our break we don't even have to do live
shows
where we can bring back contact
we don't want to worry about work
I mean we could film stuff yeah content
yeah but like that's fine too baby
however you want okay okay okay
long for the ride
uh anyway so I was just uh showing you
know the types of shops all kinds of fun
vintage shops and everything there's
also the yinzo shopping district which
is more like the high-end High fashion
this is all Tokyo this is all Tokyo
if I'm going there I'm never coming out
right and you know all of like the big
famous
um Japanese designers have stores there
and everything there's also like
Flagship stores for Louis Vuitton and
all that kind of stuff and uh I don't
know I just thought that building was
really cool include a picture of that
um
also
getting off the fashion train a little
bit
how do you feel about fun
little animal encounters because
there's all kinds of stuff like this
that you can this is the greatest
experience
of his life we are here and they let
they're they're letting us touch otters
and the Otters are going crazy look at
that one
I like being touched in their belly but
that one is being a little slow oh look
at this oh my God Ethan loves the Otters
is this Humane the Otters are cool
are you kidding me
they're so cute
all right so you know there's stuff like
that to do
Otter's not your fancy love owls how
about Little Owls Zach of your eyes you
wanna hang out in an owl Cafe that Zach
are you scared of aliens Zach avert your
eyes owls Al's not so much okay
they don't flutter right
look how cute this is so cool owls are
amazing I love owls dude yeah look at
this this could be us so why is it you
can do this in Japan but not in America
uh I think you can do it in America I
just think there's not like a culture of
doing it I mean there are like there are
things like this there's like cat cafes
there's a bunch of those here in La
um look at um look at them
all right
you're not so hot on the birds how about
little baby deer oh I mean deer okay I
mean I wonder where Dearborn are there
deer everywhere that will just hang out
around tons of people and have it is
kind of interesting how they're so cool
no in Japan like in America they'll be
like don't touch get away but here Japan
in Japan they're like uh these are
Buddhist um that's like the deer
these deer live on cookies or what what
do you just give them yeah this is a
park and they have little stands where
you can buy crackers to feed them and
stuff like that oh these years probably
the best site ever people just see them
all day
all right but you know cute petting cute
animals that's fun and all maybe not
your thing what about all of the
beautiful sights that you can see look
at this those will not be blooming okay
well you know you get the idea right
Japanese Gardens to take strolls through
and uh connect with your uh inner self
okay that's cool and all but
what about the beep [__] [__] yeah baby
what about the winning [__] get off all
of this like cute animals and you know
tranquility and [__] okay first of all
there's [__] Gundams just hanging
around a man's Lego some would say yeah
all right okay and it's just like 10
story tall like giant fighting robots
here's one that moves
in Tokyo but like here uh those big
Gundams I think are actually in one of
the very famous big shopping districts
it's just like outside one of the big
malls this is like some uh this is like
some special installation that's uh that
they did specifically to have this but
it's in public uh it is in public yeah
um also Universal Studios in Tokyo has
an entire Attack on Titan land can I see
the right VR ride
I mean you can get rescues can you can
you full screen the ride
[Music]
yeah that's crazy is there spoilers
because the show isn't finished yet
probably uh this seems to be something
from like early on in the show from
whatever that is yeah but okay cool wow
next
there's a whole ass one piece indoor
amusement park really called Tokyo One
Piece Tower yes
let me see God if we went we wouldn't
know what to do first
if we went with someone we would need to
be in charge of itinerary oh yeah we
planned it all out you know I mean
honestly since we're talking about
spending big bucks just hiring like a
professional tour guide to have somebody
if you want to translate and like that's
true that's true they kind of help you
yeah
like sometimes I know sometimes they're
nice but sometimes it's kind of a drive
I think because we would be a big group
it might be necessary because it's not
like just me and you figuring it out
it's like
you won't go to eat it's a big group
yeah not a bad idea
oops let me see this
so this is just some random video that I
found of somebody what's inside of some
of the stuff well they can't show the
rides apparently I think they secure
your phone or whatever because I tried
to find stuff like that phone the [__] I
don't know I couldn't find any videos on
like rides
hmm
but anyways you get the idea it's just a
one-piece theme thing
also
the famous Studio Ghibli which I know
that you're a huge fan of has their
Museum there
ah would you like to get on the cat bus
would you like to do that I would like
to do that and then
going along with the weeb theme there's
this whole uh I guess neighborhood uh
called Akiba akiyabara akiabara I think
that's how it said anyways this is like
this is like the nerd Central this is
the place that has the 24 7
arcades that are constantly going all
you know through the night and
everything and dance dance
who's playing dance dance there's tons
uh alley will DDR Ali's a pro Ally's a
DDR Pro yeah she's
uh nobody who cares about Sega well Sega
is uh still huge in the arcade scene
most like they're epic's one of the
biggest if not the biggest but anyways
it's just you know tons and tons of
shops and arcades and fun stuff that you
can do in this area so that's what's
going on who are these guys uh yeah they
also have um they made uh cafes
Ethan this could be us this could be
this could be you me and the boy
foreign
well it's like it's it's important it
off or whatever uh also if we go
we can finally make a segment years in
the making which one
karaoke with the [__] fine
Zach you know I'm right
Zach thoughts and Bones
karaoke is crazy in Tokyo and stuff that
they have there um I mean obviously
there's a typical place where you get a
room and they have cool ones where like
the room is super themed and all kinds
of stuff fancy and then they also have
like public ones and then they even have
uh it's a pretty common thing to have
live band karaoke there where instead of
a karaoke machine they have like a
drummer and guitar player and a baseball
one group yeah and they just like you
know they're just really talented
musicians that can play pretty much
anything and you request a song and you
can like sing with the band rather than
with the karaoke machine okay I'll be
pretty epic that is pretty interesting
all right just a few more things
American YouTubers you know do not have
the best reputation in Japan
any no trips to suicide forest for us
well that's the thing I promise if we
find it after we leave yeah we can
redeem
the American YouTube space
okay fair
we got to do it for the old red white
and blue everybody stand up everyone
stand up right now stand up
as the pilgrims
as representatives of this great nation
we promise to be respectful and
represent ourselves well as we journey
across the globe to our friends and
allies the nation of Japan
God bless Japan and God bless the United
States of America thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
and this last thing this is the last
thing
you can't get one upped by this [__]
loser how many of you guys want to go
Japan how many of you is this me rage
car okay let's I'll tell you what I
thought I know you guys are already rich
and [__] listen here's what I'll do
because I think Japan is a necessary uh
experience to have it's a it's a
beautiful country so I'll send you uh
I'll cover you guys a trip yo we gotta
go yeah listen I will get you guys what
do you mean by that I mean I I got you
this is first class
who does he think he is first class
there I'm back first class
you know what I'm saying you guys go for
a week I got you at the Ritz Carlton
Ritz Carlton he's such a [__] Goose
though it's like it's like easy for you
bro
he's so gross disgusting he's like look
how generous I am I get 100 million
dollars
I need to show him what generosity is
because I'm not as rich as him I don't
have probably not funny yeah
that's train wreck that's train wreck
yeah yeah damn it's uh the name is short
for his his moral uh fortitude so thank
you for listening and I'll see you okay
now once again I need to
I need to nudge you a bit on a
estimation right okay so I admittedly
haven't done a full budget breakdown yet
okay because it's kind of ambiguous what
we'd even want to do or whatever I mean
realistically taking a group of what
like 12 to 13
aroundish people through Japan for a
week putting them in a splice nice it's
gonna be expensive I mean this is bougie
I I would expect this to probably wind
up costing
150 150
. that's a lot by the way that's totally
fine with me right yeah you said you
said sky's the limit and you don't care
yeah and so I'm just that's rough rough
in my head I will say that was a
fantastic yeah fantastic presentation
okay okay I'm only thinking again my
only reservation here
is let's say we do bring the nanny and
we bring both boys
[Music]
like all day long they're just going to
be it like what are they going to do
that's
a problem
or we leave them
with your parents for 10 days
or help was the pants you think they'd
be okay for that long the kids never
been away from them that long
people do that right
people do that I mean
I'm you know what I I don't feel
right weighing in on that at all I think
that bringing them would be kind of a
nightmare and it's actually the reason
I'm not going this year to Israel is
because I feel like Bruce is not ready
for such a long flight it can be pretty
difficult right it's certain situations
like that did you see the mute we tried
to go to a restaurant it was a nightmare
like we barely made it did you see the
baby mute though right yeah
so I think if we do want to actually
consider it more likely if we keep them
at home so we keep them at home
and then I just it's like can we be away
from the kids for that long maybe a week
I don't know a week I mean people do
that do they yeah
for the trip I'm commenting on the the
length of the trip we could still have a
lot we don't the big thing for him is
just figuring out what to do with the
kids and I agree and to me bringing them
would be a nightmare because I want to
be able to go to those fashion places
and just be gone if I bring them it's
all about them I get to do nothing for
me
so I wouldn't want to do that
ah I'm just gonna throw this out right
now we could we could do Japan and mine
as well just saying just gonna throw it
out there as much as I would love the
way be it is just one or you know
we could stay home and you share the
love
hell no I'm not staying home this guy
doesn't leave the house give me a reason
to do something that was very good Dan
very persuasive thank you thank you
honestly if I
if in my mind I can like accept being
away from the kids that long
[Music]
theoretically
I think that would be super if we go
away for like a week I think that's
totally fine but then two days flying
I've never been away from them but I
think it's only five full days that's a
lot is that enough Dan five full days
whenever we had recently five full days
anywhere so it'll take what he could get
but you're gonna fly all the way to
Japan for five
days damn
all right who's next
I can go next damn this is Sam's the uh
fabled Ranch visit okay
[Applause]
you want to talk about the ranch no
nobody want to talk about 9 11.
I'm decked out you look incredible
I like Bahama Sam give us a twirl you
know I like the Bahamas
I've been wanting to go there
all right you guys
Japan I like it's cool whatever but the
Bahamas
next slide let's get the next slide
let's get started going fully in control
yourself hit the uh arrow keys
all right okay okay it's fun it's bougie
it's beautiful this Resort has a casino
that's cool it's relaxing and it's quick
to get there you connect in Atlanta it's
three and a half hour flight we can't
fly straight there no you can't you
can't really fly straight to Nassau from
anywhere but it's fine
three and a half hours to Atlanta then
an hour layover oh then it's fine it's
like a a 24-hour flight to Japan no it's
like 11. that's so long that's your
whole day that sounds like all right
hold on one sec Sam how much is a first
class ticket to from LA to Japan and uh
it's gonna be less and June or it's
going to be more expensive than the
Bahamas well of course I'm just curious
because uh we'd obviously have to go
first class to Japan obviously you'll
see in my price screen that's not
obvious at all but sure yeah you're
asking in June
yeah like the end of June
um uh also for first class we're looking
around 16k to 20K
more than way more than I thought what
oh my god I think I'm gonna say like
five grand yeah 16 000. staying home
sounds pretty good are you scared here
you got June 25th let's say till uh
that's Ethan's birthday we would all be
celebrating his birthday
uh yeah fifteen thousand dollars four
hundreds
fifteen that is what's happening
what's happening
no no it's fifteen thousand okay I got
it yeah I did have a little stroke how
much is a normal ticket
normal ticket
that one's probably like a thousand
there we go 15 000.com economy is a
thousand six hundred there you go wow
it was a long flight yeah I guess we're
going coach baby
if we paid that
that'd be like the whole budget of the
trip if we all got first class sorry
Santa my first class but yeah this isn't
about Japan this is about the Bahamas
it's about the Bahamas this is about the
Bahamas yeah it's a great place for a
group of homies which is us uh amazing
food and it's super instagramable great
content you can get fits off left and
right here
okay
hold on okay is there a difference
between business and first class if you
fly to Japan
business is five thousand dollars okay
okay well sorry five thousand to eight
thousand
hmm I don't know what's the difference
there go ahead Sam okay thick Resort
alert
I've stayed at this Resort before
incredible it is very very as a water
park several adult-only pools so you
don't have to deal with kids
Casino private beach mini golf course
Luxury Spa tons of shopping it's
literally like Rodeo Drive on a
beautiful island nightclubs 27
restaurants coffee bars pool sizes all
the resorts 27 restaurants yes so [__]
telling you it's sick uh in a tropical
bird sanctuary for cam yeah you're
surrounded by some blue ass water what
more could you want nothing not a lot
more than that yeah there's literally
nothing else that's everything
Ethan Hilo you guys deserve your own
Villa it's a three it's a three-bedroom
Villa that has 24 7 Butler Service 24 7
room service
otega Veneta Linens robes and slippers
God damn what right hold the phone where
are you guys staying oh I'll get there
I'll get there okay all right because
it's sick too okay uh private pool
sitting area rooftop patio it's a
perfect private pool yes
a private pool it's the perfect place
for the nanny and the kids to have down
time
The Nanny and the kids to have down time
yeah it's three bedrooms so you guys can
have one Nanny can have one and the kids
can have one
unless they share one with you then
that's fine too right and then the crew
can stay here it's just the six bedroom
version okay good I wanted to make sure
that it has six baths so
I mean come on what are the prices on
these this
Villa is eighteen thousand dollars a
night
but we're all staying there wow right
but it's for everyone right and then
yours was like 10.
so 28 000. look
yeah just wait six
we're going for well we're going for a
week right okay wait
18 000 a night now if if you guys were
all to get separate rooms and well
there's couples so they're beginning to
be like
seven rooms
right and if we're staying at a nice
hotel
it's going to run at least a thousand a
night
right for a nice hotel room
yeah I guess I'm just thinking like how
much is it gonna cost us
no matter where we go to get everyone a
nice hotel room well so yeah I'll I have
a chart that can that will be a good
breakdown for that okay okay more on the
resort it's a celeb Zone celebrities are
spotted here all the time so you know
it's bad and boujee even the bachelor in
Real Housewives Yep this is when they
were they were just there even Zach's
terrible season they shot there
okay possible Excursion we can go swim
with pigs real cute we can have a
private boat take us to pig island and
we can swim with the cafe in Japan look
at how this place does look pretty uh
yeah it is is it dog friendly oh wait I
can't breathe no stop we're trying to I
mean I don't know it would probably be
pricey to bring them out we are not
bringing dogs bad idea okay here's the
cost breakdown
see this is what I'm talking about
bowling on a budget go ahead so
we could do this trip and we could be
balling and having a great time for
about 68k how do you figure that's for
that is if we didn't do the Villas
that's if we got the nicest hotel room
okay okay in the resort okay so that's
seven rooms
at
for six nights and how much is it per
night for the rooms
um I think this one was based off of
like an eight or nine hundred dollar
room I can't remember okay
that's a lot more reasonable so yeah
um and then food uh food's expensive
there just no problem
um but I looked at uh past receipts from
when we went and I did like a sort of a
per couple breakdown about 250 a day
loving the mate uh
the details here yeah it's awesome
options and then the Excursion is only I
mean only but it's 3 800 bucks because
it's about 299 per person that's just to
kick it with pigs yeah it's more than
kicking it with pigs is swimming with
pigs
and uh yeah so flights uh that is for if
we all flew like comfort
um so yeah what's comfort
all right I I guess on Delta it's like
behind first class there's like there's
just like a main thing
yeah yeah it's just like a slightly
better seat Okay then if we want to do
absolute juicer mode
we could do it we could blow it out for
213 000. so break that down so flights
that's if we all flew first it would be
about 27 or sorry I can't 26 20 26 27 or
so actually only like a little over
double the price of the normal flights
yeah really okay it's a lot more
reasonable to Japan
uh psychos the hotel if we did both of
those Villas it would be 160 000. that
seems a bit excessive oh
to me though yeah food um it would be
pretty much the same I added a little
just you know give or take and then hey
I don't see a location like this being
needed for six nights to stay there
right if we didn't go to somewhere like
that it would be nice I mean six six
days would make a lot more sense with
the kids
to me I mean we can just go and really
just not worry about the fan we could
all hang out go to the casino eat at all
these restaurants sounds great
wake up do it I don't think there's
enough to do in a place like that
there's nice there is there's so much to
do just follow Sam's leading I mean you
know that's just me if you like the
beach there's definitely like there's so
much to do but there's also like options
for excursions I put like if we all did
massages if we swam with pigs if we went
snorkeling if we went on a jet ski trip
you could rent boats you could play golf
mini golf there's like so much other
things to do
so that's if we went so I know I'm cool
with the ultimate juicer mode
probably makes more sense to just get us
like nice individual hotels rooms and
that's and that's cool but otherwise
everything else on the absolute juicer
mode I'm totally down for awesome
so if you consider that
where you would just be essentially if
you if you're reducing
the hotel will be 40 instead of 160 so
it's minus 120
yeah I mean it's expensive
then it's all under a hundred thousand
options there's also um I did that based
off of like an eight or nine hundred
dollar room I think there was rooms that
were like
A Thousand Eleven Hundred I think 1100
was the most expensive that I saw some
people are saying we can get a private
jet for 50K
oh that's still double
yeah I mean first class
also for we would probably still have to
connect because it's a small plane I
doubt it could fly straight to Nassau
direct would be [__] baller
yeah
but also bed private jets are bad vibes
right we don't like those
if I wrote If I write coach could I keep
the difference
you all right first class oh you're
thinking maybe no
sure yeah all right that's it yeah you
can keep the difference
so we'll put that we'll put that around
a hundred thousand
like oh like this yeah with the normal
rooms
that's adding like an extra 20 just for
whatever yeah
an extra 20 I'll give everyone for
gambling
everyone gets like 2K to gamble with
Vibes so then that's like a hundred
thousand
yeah they also have a Rolex store Zach
I mean if Ethan wants to buy me a Rolex
with my shirt I don't have to go on this
trip you know
Zach says buy me a Rolex I don't want to
go buy me a Rolex yeah interesting I'm
easy man
well
theoretically how much is a new Rolex
because it's about it comes out to about
12 000 or well depending on the watch
but you know or I could just have the
cash you know and pick it out myself
my old boss used to say no show no dough
meaning if you skip the Christmas party
no bonus
Zach has made his intentions very clear
okay Sam I thought that was very
persuasive all right thank you Sam yeah
me too
I love the Bahamas it's a lot less
complicated I'll tell you that get up
there
you are all right okay we're gonna love
donuts for six days
um like I said personally I don't think
there's enough to do there for six
nights so where how long would you want
to go for a place like this I would do
three three that's not long enough I
think you kind of get tired of like the
beach okay three full days yeah three
full days so it'd be one two three
well she was saying six nights that's
technically like seven so when you
arrive that doesn't count as a full day
no so it would be
you arrive
one two three you leave the next day so
it'd be five nights
it's considered four nights if you're
doing five days
it is
um
arrive one two three oh yeah yeah you're
right four nights four nights is that
too little Sam
that's three full days
we could do we could do four what if we
just compromise and add another day I'm
just I'm not saying one way or the other
I'm not saying that I want to do this
ELO's afraid that six that was just one
feedback point that I had well let's
talk it out because we have to decide
today we are deciding today yeah okay I
honestly in like the true very very true
I think Japan is like way cooler so
hard to follow up Japan
but that looks like a trip I would want
to do the one that sent proposed but
it's not like
up here I like Sam's trip that's more my
speed but I see we have we're having a
conflict
all right go ahead love
Dan is switching for you
um I don't know just just tell me when
you want next slide all right all right
so I am getting a little bit worried
that you guys are like going back and
forth about like ten thousand twenty
thousand because this is a
we're gonna
almost blow our budget here listen no um
there's no budget it's just when I see
that it just feels silly to spend
forty thousand dollars a night
where we can get our own hotel rooms
it's just not that much better
go ahead love sky's the limit right okay
well that's great to hear cause we're
renting a [__] juicer Yacht for a
week
um
uh juicer y'all like a big big 200 foot
yaw this is possible all right so let's
go to the next uh page here so let's
start off with some quick facts right
luxury accommodations
uh we're talking like like top 0.0.01
luxury accommodations not not anything
like those hotel rooms Butlers whatever
we're gonna have a 30 30 man crew just
juicing helping us uh and we'll get in
more into the crew later I have to tell
you love yeah I've been watching I've
seen every single episode of below deck
I just started it every single one and I
know what goes on below deck my friend
well that's that's none of us our
business well it is when the chef
doesn't show up and then like uh the the
junior deckhand ends up like uh throwing
some ground beef together and serving
that out or when the boat gets stuck in
the dock or when the engine doesn't work
that won't happen to us okay
all right exclusivity and privacy that's
obviously um comes with it we're not
going to share our space with no
um peasants uh there will be just us
does everyone get their own room on this
yacht yes uh absolutely if we if we
choose to go the ball once we can take a
smaller yaw if you if you would feel
more comfortable over that but yeah we
can make it possible uh next up
customized experience
um I know for a fact that all the crew
are very different in in what they want
to do we have seen these uh this on like
the presentations everyone's different
so we can make a very tailored
experience for each crew member and yeah
um unmatched scenery for obvious reasons
access remote locations we can come we
can go to places that people don't go
otherwise like what uh like
um a hidden Beach that you can only get
to with a big bow okay yeah stuff like
that we can do like we kind of cover
that choice of on-board activity kind of
copy that we can do like fishing diving
all that kind of stuff whatever whatever
like money money can buy
uh okay professional crew including
nannies now uh we'll get more later damn
yeah exactly that's my point yeah yeah
those people are are degenerates I tell
you man in that show all right
that's great because I I have a I have a
fix for that too Around the Clock
service yada yada Unforgettable memories
yada yada next slide please
uh we can recreate some pretty memorable
uh moments maybe in history here
obviously uh first pictures from with a
video of you and idubbbs uh copying uh
the suck
uh we can do that that's just funny meme
stuff nothing special obviously Elon
Musk
um weird
um body whatever
next next up uh kind of cost breakdown
as you guys can see there's a wide range
oh you spent all the money
you've spent every that single Cent yeah
well we can't even go aboard like over
the body no
300 to 500 000 for the yacht now uh
depending on what kind of a juicer yard
we get obviously if we spend 500 000 on
the yacht we won't be able to do the the
other stuff as well as juicy hold on
hold on so if you spend 500 000 on the
yacht it doesn't include food and
beverages it does it does it's a it's a
sharker so it will so so we wouldn't be
paying separately for that stuff no but
I'm saying you can we can we can like
order like [__] a whole ass Baguio
cow on the boat we can we can really
Juice It Up we can really Juice It Up
all that stuff the goal is not to spend
every single dollar well I do think you
said there was no budget there isn't it
no I did I did so but more money more
memorable more money more memories well
yeah my money more memories like they
always say yep okay go ahead break it
down
so food beverage like we can go crazy
right like this guy is the limit we can
order we could order Chick-fil-A and
like we could order Chick-fil-A kitchen
like we could like could do [__] like
that weird crazy [__] I'm ordering like
so we're getting a half a million dollar
yacht and then we're gonna eat
Chick-fil-A yeah
for fifty thousand dollars
right yep yep yep I mean my point is to
prove that the sky is the sky is the
limit
you can do a lot of [__] with all this
money water toys and Equipment you can
rent uh [__] uh water skis
um a yet Pat water yet packs they should
have it yeah I think it comes with it it
should all be on the boat right it does
come with a lot of juicer stuff but you
can go beyond that is the whole point of
this thing like you can really cram out
of every single penny you can get more
you could get like a submarine you can
rent a little one-man submarine really
cool yeah one of those in gtas where
there's like a big bubble can we really
rent a submarine
yeah of course
I haven't looked into that specifically
sounded like Theodore Theodore started
saying that yeah of course yeah I would
love to get a summary that'd be fun I
know for a fact you can but it's true
it's probably going to be pricey
especially to get it to the location you
need like
a driver
yes
anyhow I'm just pointing out you can do
a lot of crazy stuff entertainment we
can order like
crazy stuff right we can order our
favorite singer maybe or it would have
to be like a b tier celebrity like
celebrity singer not eight years no um
um like what are we like a Vanilla Ice
yeah maybe something like that yeah
he'll do it for 500 bucks man
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay okay uh crew
and stuff this current staff is not uh
the actual crew this is like above the
yacht staff so this is like Nani's extra
cook like you can order celebrity cook
Maybe
travel to ya I just put 20K I figured
that'd be possible 20K I don't know
total is the goal like you you can kind
of change like cheaper yacht like more
expensive food
next one please
and so I got a couple
um examples of Serenity is that for the
one of the ones from blow deck that
sounds familiar I don't know maybe these
are juicer Yachts though this is the top
of the line
um so we got lucky lady icon and
serenity let's go to the first slide
here so this is one of the cheaper ones
so as you guys can see lucky lady y'all
uh it says add your subtitles here
um
price 370k a week now if we're doing
this would you guys be down to be just
be on below deck the show
the Titanic workers probably be cheaper
they gotta give it a discount for that
right yeah yeah yeah
uh but like just look at the image here
to the right like what an insane hangout
area just kicking back here after a
night of full or after a day of full of
activities eating good maybe some
Popeyes whatever like that yeah
um
yeah Popeyes dude that's in the budget
it's accounted for it's not uh that's
not the point
oh [__] all right no pulp ice I guess
233 foot long that's kind of like a
juicer uh this specific one has 10
sleeping uh I don't know I I'll sleep
wherever you guys take the rooms well no
if we're if there's three or there's
this is three couples
then we would we would only need like
yeah that'd fit us all everyone would
get that okay well there you go 15 crew
that's kind of on the lower end in my
opinion
waterfall this specific one has a
waterfall yakuzi with overflow warding
pool whatever that means massive Sunday
yada yada yup juicer next up discrete
areas what are they implying
and that's up to you Grandpa's feeling a
little frisky
yeah yeah and these are all pictures
from the yaw uh like insane hangout
areas just look at the the left bottom
one wow just wow
[Laughter]
it's insane like it's crazy and uh
bottom right we got some uh activities
we got a yeah whatever cool stuff next
up uh similar yeah five hundred thousand
dollars it's a little bit more expensive
uh 14 sleeping
um 18 crew were getting up there uh
impressive beach club with Joe you know
what else I I'm supposed to leave a 20
tip in cash for these [__] people
yeah no that would that would be a
hundred thousand dollars of cash
well crazy even though they're not
American because that's like an American
thing based on what I've seen in below
deck you gotta you have to tip the crew
like 20 because they like work on tips
like I I don't think that's [__] up
it's like slavery no it's good it's
crazy yeah
and then they go over how much they then
they go back and judge you
oh my
well we got like an infinity pool on a
boat in the ocean dude massage room
sitting in my room sheesh okay next stop
uh this is just a video I guess we can
like
um just look through it a little bit
yeah just click through the video a
little bit random spots I don't know if
anyone is here or not oh yeah oh yeah
look just look at this beauty modern uh
Swedish minimalism maybe I don't know
look at this look at this stuff wow
that's like better than a average hotel
and like this [__] with a mini fridge
like you'll have like a massive kitchen
you can get all that juice from there so
no mini fridges next up
uh that's just some pictures next stop
uh next up this is the big juicer boat
this is one that I think that we would
settle on at that same price
yeah it's yeah but there are these crew
members yeah this is a good deal this is
a good deal this one sleeps 28. 28. what
is it what is this what's on this an
army like a military
I don't know we can invite friends some
uh friends and family stuff like that
you know I'm uh this whole trip it's not
really that party I mean it could be
like a massive juicer drinking party but
I'm gonna see it like a fun just hang
out uh family whatever get together so
this is for the kids like kids can come
along whatever that's true that is
actually a good benefit it would be fun
to bring the kids on this yeah and I'll
get into that more into more later
spacious Sunday Clark jacuzzi yada yada
air conditioner I don't know why that is
in there it's kind of like okay uh next
up uh okay here we're getting to the
child friendly part uh so literally
infinite amount of activities swimming
water games fishing marine life
encounters uh treasure hunts um it said
on the page that the crew and you guys
have a other different view of the crew
I guess on there but they they are down
to do like treasure hunter games for the
kids okay for the kids yeah yeah and
they'll set up things for the kids
specifically there are they're
apparently trained to work with kids a
lot of them stargazing movie Nights
Beach excursions uh with Nani and
trained yacht Personnel arts and crafts
you know just for the kids fun stuff fun
stuff the stargazing would be epic out
there yeah
um and here's some more more like I
guess advanced stuff for the kids or the
family basically educational activities
yada Beach excursions like they they
bring stuff they put up like a whole
tent yeah they hate doing that yeah but
they'll do it they'll do it oh yeah
they'll write about it yeah island
hopping that's honestly like it says for
the kids but this is basically for I I
think all of this stuff would be awesome
island hopping exploring different kind
of environments if I'm paying 500 000
I'm not stepping foot in that local town
dude well that's the thing oh every
second all right fair enough but the
thing is that local town could be any
town that you want so it could be a cool
town maybe who knows
um activities for us more specifically
um this is gonna we can go to the next
slide
um Spa and Wellness you know relaxing
there's going to be Spa people on there
whatever doing whatever scuba diving
snorkeling five already
Duke and uh she stay later yeah but even
all right let's how many more just oh
three more we have Cameron and I'm sorry
three more three more I can race through
this pretty fast here go ahead yeah
mine's pretty far water games you know
all that fun stuff visit local city uh
rent super cars fancy restaurants can be
set up by the crew food food exploring
relaxing next
this is the thing I asked you guys as
you guys can see on the top that's the
both crew and that's the crew uh right
so I figured we you guys would bring
your nannies or uh whatever you guys
have set up already I'm sure they would
love to be on the boat yes
um crew costs there that's included uh
yacht crews are trained in all the like
a bunch of stuff food
next slide
no so no no no not this by the way
courtesy of Ryan Ryan or Harvey uh
helping me with some photoshops here
shout out and you guys can see we've got
Chick-fil-A's we've got some French hot
dogs brisket all that good stuff
um all different flavors a yacht food we
can go to the next slide uh they have
cooks and if you guys don't prefer the
yacht cook we buy a cook we like bring a
cook with us
yacht crew delivery see they can deliver
[__] I read they can go into the town by
Chick-fil-A never mind you guys don't
like that Excursion grilling can Juice
It Up on the beach and all that [__] all
love uh next up go anywhere so this is
the kind of the good part with my mine I
think I am not suggesting a place that
is all in your hands we can go anywhere
in the world so we can go to the next
slide is that true because from what
I've seen you go to where the
the yacht is located and then you stay
in that area but you can there's Yachts
all over the world that we can shock
yeah so pretty much so Greek Islands
this is one of my favorites I love Greek
Greek uh Greece I've been there once
very beautiful very pretty next up uh
Caribbean you know oh yeah let's be
[__] Pirates
Italian cars that's pretty cool or the
North Pole [__] let's go why not
obviously it would change the activities
a little bit but uh pretty cool you can
do it that's it
much money
I do appreciate the uh effort to spend
every single dollar
definitely the most expensive one yes
sir so thank you for that yeah
we're trying
he's in front of you
coming up all right
we are cruising baby
got some dead air but that's all good
hey guys hey how are we feeling
all right Olivia said okay her
Powerpoint we've got dollar bills in the
picture
where are we going what Olivia wants to
do with 620k mm-hmm
I thought about a little a lot of
different places
I looked up how do I stay in a castle
[Music]
I learned a lot of new things like
there are a lot of whales in Alaska
which I didn't know I was thinking about
a cruise to Alaska
that really threw me off so
and all that thinking and learning I
think that I found the place
you can stay in The Bachelor Mansion
yourself for 7 500 a night on Airbnb I
know right so you'll see what what else
in Calabasas what I'll drive there yeah
you'll see what else I've got Sam you
gotta love that Bachelor Manor I do love
it I'll save my thoughts for us okay
okay that's fair
Bachelor Mansion Agora Hills California
oh it's in Agora bro I can walk here
yeah it's great it's literally so
beautiful Zach it it pleases your need
to stay home that's true this is very
fair I like this awesome love that
private Chef that would be sick yeah
then I got an idea
have you guys ever heard of LARPing yes
yeah live action role playing is what
LARPing is a live action role-playing
game is a form of role-playing game
where the participants physically
portray their characters the players
pursue goals within a fictional setting
represented by real world environments
while interacting with each other in
character
mock employee Rosa oh my God
are you kidding me oh my God and it
doesn't even have to be roses it could
be something else we could have will you
accept this so does someone have to
leave no no no it's just like you know
when someone gets the date Rose yeah
it'll be like every night it'll be like
that but we'll we'll all dress up and
it'll be like a rose Sarah just for
funsies yeah for funsies LARPing
we'd be LARPing right yeah so Ela a
different look for each Rose ceremony
like are you kidding me try not to say
mother challenge
impossible look at her on the carpet she
looks so good
that leftover dough maybe we
commissioned Chris Harrison
maybe we have an out of retirement
yeah I was thinking maybe the chat will
have some problems with that so an
alternate
unproblematic because this is
I love Mark Wahlberg wait wait which one
did Mark Wahlberg host uh
he's an empath so he's a great house
he's perfect I follow him on Twitter
he's incredible oh isn't he Mark L
Wahlberg is that how he goes by yeah
that's what he goes by I made sure that
I included all of that so everyone I was
there yeah yeah there's another one did
you guys know there's another Mark
Wahlberg
um
leftover dough Perkins for everybody
okay
don't you accept my rose
bin
ah wait so give me an estimate
women 7 500 a night 7 500 a night well I
want to include like
private Chef yeah yeah yeah yeah then I
think I mean it couldn't go over like
100k right no yeah we could do 100 for
that so yeah that's my pitch but there's
no travel either yeah we just drive
there like a carpool if we could
everyone could get a limousine I'll send
them pick you up oh helicopter
helicopter oh maybe think about it oh I
don't know Kobe
yes I retract my statement he didn't he
die like yeah it was right there too
yeah it was uh it was on this
presentation's all about Good Vibes yeah
I just want to say it was on minolino's
wedding day really we were on the way to
our wedding and they're just like Kobe
wasn't that long ago April 20. uh what
or it was January sorry January 2020
yeah
wait he died on your guy's wedding day
yeah oh damn oh my God we didn't know
you guys back then yeah that's what's so
confusing it doesn't seem like a long
ago wow
well well done Bachelor Mansion thank
you so much
all right cam is coming up so we have
Cameron and then who else do we have
left
okay okay
I think most of these are sure yeah
luxury train
from Milan Milan to Swiss Alps hello
everybody
hello okay so how do I how do we like
Royal Tenenbaum and that's the Vibes I
was going for so I got my my uh Euro
trash outfit on right now just to get
you in the mood I like it this one's for
you Lou
oh
[Music]
okay
all right so H3 pod squad takes a luxury
train from Milan to the Swiss Alps uh
the backstory to this is well honestly I
just want to present a different option
no there has been a lot of European
pitches right now and I've been
listening to a lot of Tyler the creators
uh last album uh call me if you get lost
and on the sixth track hot one blows DJ
Drama shouts out we just landed in
Geneva it's in Switzerland so I thought
hey I'll do a Switzerland pitch okay uh
so I found this uh eight day Excursion
that's seven nights it's uh you take
luxury trains through starting in Milan
and you uh go through Sweden or I mean
Switzerland sorry uh for seven nights
and what are you doing between there's
like little extra like on the website
there's little options and they stop for
a day and somewhere yeah yeah and I
think we can begin in Italy and we can
spend a little bit of time there if we
want and uh uh you know taking the
sights there's a lot of like fashion
it's a fashion Capital it's fun it's
cool love it uh Da Vinci's Last supper's
there there's a lot of cool art uh some
more views of the city I'm trying to
blaze through this right now
um
yeah it's a nice historic City you know
it's Italy it's Europe uh Italian food's
good yes it is sure it is yeah uh
there's some pesto there if you want
some pesto you know oh all kinds of good
stuff I don't know if it's served like
that but I found this picture online I
thought oh dude
I don't know if that's traditionally how
the Italian serve it but I don't think
so I could be mistaken the picture I
found on Google
you know when we're in Italy you can
make play Make Believe As The Godfather
in real life you know it's always a fun
time to me on the day of my uh Italian
trip uh and then honestly I don't really
know much about Chad or I don't know
about Milan so I asked jet gbt for some
okay okay two awesome fashion tips okay
or some uh travel tips there if you want
to read through this later feel free
yeah and now look at the Swiss Alps
Adventure uh we're gonna be traveling to
Switzerland on a luxury train I took
this uh picture from
whatever that wasn't Anderson movie is
you know life would be good hotel
beautiful Grand Budapest Hotel uh life
would be so much better if every day was
like a Ricola coffee I do love ricolas
they got a beautiful backdrop in these
commercials and I've always wanted to go
okay uh so this is a view unable to play
video air awesome I love it uh well
imagine how beautiful it would be
um this is just the breakdown of
itinerary they this uh service I found
covers the hotels and everything it was
all luxury stuff it was about oh you
stay in a hotel you stay on the train
yeah so you hop on different trains
um and you stay at luxury hotels
overnight okay and you do some places
you stay two nights in a row and stuff I
don't know okay and then uh the Swiss
Alps just seem so incredible and Sublime
we should try to be on the rails for
once on the rails this is just a bunch
of
thank you
and yeah and the trip ends in Zurich
which is a very beautiful city and I'd
like to go through there sometime there
and that's it uh it's a great big
beautiful world out there and I'm
grateful to travel Anywhere With You
very much
honestly these are all so fun like each
one of these would be an awesome trip to
take yeah I like the idea of the luxury
train but what threw me off is like
getting off to go to a different Hotel
every time this is like a schlep yeah I
mean I just found the service we could
probably find other ones that stay on
like a luxury train the whole time but
thank you Cameron thank you boss
breakdown I don't know do you know how
much one of those tickets cost uh for
the for the luxury train service there's
about 3K ahead okay so yeah yeah well we
have to fly out to Europe right probably
looking at
maybe if I have to guess like 200 000
what do you think you're less
less for sure just because everybody
needs to fly to Europe I was yeah yeah
no I think it's under 100.
I don't know I'm not good with numbers I
plead the fifth okay all right well this
is on the chip side compared all right
we have Ian
yes
next and Ian will close us out
are you sure we're gonna decide here at
this moment we have to yeah really based
on what that's the game that's the game
on the rules that you made up yeah it's
my rules
that's right the rules that I made up
right
we need to Australia I like Australia
I'm here to make a case for it yeah and
and not too many people go there too
often because how far it is all right
that's why they call it the land down
under if it's all the way in the
Southern Hemisphere and it's usually
forgotten about I figured I should make
a case for them all right forgotten
country of Australia
okay baby TV do this every year I know
we should do much just what can you use
a favor just hold 30 percent
and pay us back yeah go ahead
um so yes I think it's important to
remember that a big chunk of the H3
viewership comes from Australia huge fan
base there and then Aussies are known to
be all about the Good Vibes they're
lovely people so sweet they have a super
laid-back culture everyone calls each
other mate that's really cool I agree
and then let's not forget about all the
look at these beautiful people it's
great examples of some Aussies Erin
always smiling so sad rip to the go dude
all right and then when did Lou die
and and the others of course you guys
already know all about them and their
contribution to the world
and they're very unique animals in
Australia right you can't find them
anywhere else marsupials
and there's nothing on the left yeah
that's a Quaker a kawaka dude they smile
like that I love them so much I [__]
love them oh man yeah so cute right and
you can so that's another reason you can
go and get a cute selfie with these
that's like the cutest animal what is
wrong with it he looks like the mouse is
the dress like Cinderella yeah Yep
they're so beautiful
excuse me sorry I'm losing my voice it
seems oh no and kangaroos you can't
forget about the kangaroo
very fascinating so a lot of people
think they're scary but some can be
affectionate too look I don't know if
you guys have seen that one on the left
is looking scary
that one is on the on the droids very
much yeah that one's also real I didn't
um
[__] me
um so this is a video they're just very
fascinating creatures because they could
be aggressive or affectionate kangaroo
you never know what to expect
here's a kangaroo holding someone's dog
oh this is selling this dude
she's squaring up with a kangaroo
punches him in the face and walks away
you gotta appreciate that I feel like if
he punched a human in the face he would
get angry and attack but the kangaroo
oh
knows to cut his losses okay so we can
put but they're also very strong what is
that now what about that is am I
supposed to take it oh it's just fun to
watch she's just fashionable yeah
because you don't know what to expect
with them interesting and also they
could be as I said affectionate too look
how sweet
so by getting people oh
lots of kangaroos are known to give
kisses to humans it's very sweet that's
cute
it's a punch
es
next Arrow oh thanks okay and then in
addition to the Exotic Wildlife you also
have very diverse Landscapes this means
there's something there for everybody
right
this one here this is one of the seven
natural wonders seven natural wonders of
the world it's a huge coral reef and
it's also the largest organism in the
world
and this is the Pink Lake that's really
pretty
so I want you to just for a moment maybe
close your eyes and imagine taking a
Jeep ride through all of these beautiful
diverse places
Australia I have daintree um rainforest
it's the oldest rainforest in the world
lots of rare species we have Tasmania
Island which is actually it has the
cleanest air in the whole wide world and
also the Great Ocean Road it's kind of
like PCH but in Australia and it's one
of the world's most scenic Coastal
drives cool
now Australia's a pretty big country are
these all close are you together I know
this idea some are apart but that's what
I was thinking too because you can like
travel you can take cruises and you know
there's different from one place to
another travel yeah it depends what you
want to do there's just there's so much
now now this okay interesting approach
go ahead and yeah I know you might be
thinking why would I want to do that I
think personal growth is is a good
reason to want to do this a lot of us
are either afraid of Fighters or like
you know crocodiles and there they have
like huge spiders and not all of them
are dangerous they're not like poisonous
oh okay only only some but not like most
of them are and also there's a place
called crocosaurus Cove where you can
actually swim with the crocodiles wow ew
She's kissing the crocodile [__] that
what how are you gonna say you oh she's
yeah
yeah you
yeah it's gross and also I don't want to
die but it's fine glass
oh and that's it that's it all right
that's it
I I like that the PowerPoint looks like
a Khan Academy video I don't know if
anyone else caught that but
that sounds great we can go
square up with kangaroos let spiders
crawl over our face
I love it and kiss a crocodile very good
all right finally we have Ian
an airline Pilot's advice get the renew
new passport started ASAP could be a
long process really but I'm assuming
everyone has a passport
uh did you get your shots and their
shots I got my shots do we need a
passport to go to the Caribbean
uh yes uh me yes
does everyone have a renewed passport I
don't have a passport I don't I do
quit
but you don't have a passport period
baby I've only ever been in Canada and
they have like an enhanced license what
dude that takes a while how did that
happen
go your whole life without a passport
all right give everybody start working
on them passports yeah
thanks for the tip uh all right a good
tip apparently Violet didn't even think
about it Marlin thank you
go ahead Ian all right hello hello hello
hello hello hello hello or should I say
uh
you know that I've been practicing I've
been practicing
that translates to hello in case you
guys miss me
yeah yeah yeah uh so yeah pack your
baguettes ladies and gentlemen because
we're going to France
and there's little I made that little
baguette some suitcase player
but not just a trip to Paris because
it's kind of boring you know what
everyone does it's neutral right obvious
obvious we're going south okay we're
heading down
the coast
or aka the French Riviera okay I like
that French Riviera it's very beautiful
very Scenic so I have a five step plan
on how to pull this off all right this
is a little first class shot step one
first class flight to nice it's
pronounced nice I Googled that the
second largest airport in France ice
cold Coca-Cola TV entertainment pretzels
you know how it goes The Vibes are
Immaculate I took that photo last time I
was on a plane because I was just so
happy about that complimentary Coke it
hits unlike any other Coke in the world
really that mild I've got the pressure
yeah the air pressure does something
yeah was it the little Ken
no it was the they gave me the full size
I was you know they knew I was a high
roller
uh okay step two we get off at nice we
relaxed beautiful five-star hotel right
on the water okay this is one of them I
found it looks very gorgeous that's the
view of the room you know as a very like
uh Marie Antoinette Vibes in there
step three after day of two day or two
of pampering we take the 30 minute trip
up the coast to Monaco we hang out for a
day you know we see the sides this and
that
once again luxury hotel you know you
guys
right Monsieur mademas
Shredder went behind the uh
yeah that wall
we lost the dog they're up to no good
there
is Lena here
where's Lena
uh Lena
can you grab a shredder went behind the
set wall
yeah I don't want him to go potty there
or something
he's coming out can you check Discord
Lena
oh there he is my Shredder's like what
the hell do I do okay all right go ahead
uh okay that's one of the hotels uh in
Monaco uh it's you know right on the
Ocean looks beautiful beautiful it's
fine step four the following day we all
rent Bugattis right this is I I only I
added this after love told me what he's
doing you don't have to rent Buca you're
just trying to sink some money I was
trying to say he threw me off a little I
thought I was going too cheap I'd love
to rent like a Comedians in Cars Getting
Coffee tiny little toy car uh to cruise
around as well that would be very nice
we drive that
now this is potentially flexible
depending on how the the group is
feeling we could either go south stay in
France
or we could go up the coast to Italy up
to Genoa or there's beautiful you know
Italian food Italian Seaside towns
or we do the really bougie option where
we we drive down through can
you know where the celebrities can
and then we go
step five Dawn the final step we cruised
past Ken Landing in beautiful Saint cro
pay
you know beautiful Seaside once again
you just we have the town we eat we swim
you know how it goes right
we walk around that's a hotel on the
right five-star hotel of course
um from there we fly back to the
beautiful place we call home Los Angeles
United States I'll be so relieved to go
back there obviously after that
Excursion that's it that's it
[Applause]
I mean Italy is the other place that I
would really love to go okay anything in
Europe would be awesome all right well
but yeah so so hard first of all we
gotta throw up a pole
okay so here's the thing
um because there's so many options nine
um I'll tell you the ones that I think
are the are the best ones oh okay I'll
make a narrow it down like that
okay what were you gonna say well I I
just used an off-site poll thing though
well go ahead we'll do that then four
options also the way I set it up you
tell me if you like this my only fear is
that people are gonna get confused but I
guess if we talk about it right now it
won't be so bad
um doing it uh
doing it like this ranked choice
rank choice is fine you see this so you
like
the top one is your first choice and
then each one has a lot of work one left
yeah to just be like pick three
uh or two pick two
okay can you do that uh yeah give me a
minute
so
as we're setting up the pulp I'll tell
you the ones that I'm liking
my favorite is
Japan
and the Caribbean
I have to say
I've been wanting to go crazy
now the Caribbean is a lot less
complicated
one thing I also want to say I'm not
sure I want to bring the kids I just
want to go have fun oh I don't want to
bring the kids either but like because I
feel like it's one of the pluses there
was that we could bring the kids no I
don't want to bring the kids to the
Caribbean we'll leave them at home but
one if we go for like four nights it's
still shorter
and there's way less traveling so we'll
it's not like you know an 11 hour flight
we're still close to me it's like five
days instead of you know like 10. it's a
big difference yeah I'm I'm comfortable
going for five days go to the Caribbean
where seven to ten days seems just like
a little bit too long for how old they
are you know
in my opinion I mean you know
that's what I'm thinking I think we
should also ask your parents
how long they would be we've been to
stay with the boys with help
but let's just because it's not only up
to us this is also what we what could
let's just assume for the sake of this
that they're down I think they'll be
down with all the help and stuff they'll
be fine okay
all right so damn it okay I think I got
it all set up so it's gonna be
multiple choice you have to pick three
everybody who votes on this will pick
their top three or do you want to if you
want to think about content two if you
want anything about content
Japan is like definitely Japan would be
crazy by a thousand percent because the
other location is just like a beach
there's no content to do debatable uh
Bachelor Mansion no he's saying it is
between Japan and
um yeah I guess correct all right so I'm
gonna link the poll and chat and
everybody the poll will be you pick your
top two dude the Caribbeans fire because
like you can gamble
apparently gambling is uh illegal in
Japan there are casinos but they're all
run by the Yakuza which sounded a little
uh I'm not sure yeah sounds like an
adventure dude what are you talking
about yeah
all right so the poll is up guys all
right I just everyone who's invested and
I'm gonna start spamming it and then
click the straw poll
you want me to is this the two you like
it says pick two people don't mean to
call you out man because I'm horrible at
spelling but you spelled Dearborn wrong
but it's okay oh sorry about that it's
all good I can only pick two did we not
just explain this to everybody you're
picking two you picked two everybody
Frank says one two yes two that's
correct
so as the votes come in here
Japan is a clear winner
and Bahamas is a clear second winner hmm
so the question is really
let's be real going to Japan
we'd have to go for at least seven days
to make it like worth all that travel
all right
do you genuinely think that we can leave
the kids
for a whole week
yes I think it would be hard but you
know for us but I think they would be
fine they would be fine you think I
think it would be harder for us than for
them
we would feel guilty
so I don't have everybody they know
they'll have their grandparents or help
but okay so let's do the math then how
many nights will we need to be in Japan
we're talking
we want seven full days
so that would be that would be nine if
we wanted seven full days
because it's 11. I thought you mean
seven in total seven seven total will
give us five full days I think that's
plenty don't you guys did Dan five full
days is that enough
listen man I'll take what I can get
that's all that's what I've been saying
I mean when you ask like what would you
like to do and I gave the like 10 day
option I mean yeah that'd be great but
obviously I understand I can't yeah I am
busy people you got kids there's a lot
of complicating factors if you want to
do five days we do five days okay five
days maybe the crew can stick around a
little
the crew can kick back a little bit
interesting things or whatever you know
the crew can have a fun time I hadn't
even considered that yeah I mean I guess
why not if you're already there we don't
got kids okay right
interesting
uh you would pay for that Kim I'll pay
for it if we get the time off yeah I'll
pay for it yeah we all we're all taking
two weeks off okay yeah during this time
honestly I kind of feel like it's almost
an opportunity for us that we should
just take because when are we gonna get
once we have another baby when are we
gonna take a fun trip like this it does
something we're not okay I would like do
you think we could go for
six full days
so that would be eight days
parents I don't know but I feel like
people do that
you think so dude
and they're not even like in the very
beginning you know like they're not like
a newborn right now
okay so let's say six full days Dan
that would be eight days total right two
travel days six days there now we
wouldn't be able to do first class
because [__] that yeah I don't care
about that crazy
uh it's a lot better than just a
domestic flight isn't it I think it's a
lot bigger I think is that much better
there's economy
first class and then there's business
class how much is business class for
these flights I think AB said eight
thousand yeah okay I think I would want
to know what what it actually gets yeah
exactly because I've been on planes
where it's like literally like five more
inches of space there was a bunch of
people correcting me but you guys
understand that changing it by one day
changes it by you know a couple thousand
potentially
what were people saying in the chat oh
it was like two thousand dollars cheaper
or three thousand okay yeah the big
thing for me is like laying down if you
can lay down in business then
then it's worth it but if it's like a
little extra leg space [__] all that
right what even is the difference
between first class and business if
you're flying to Japan uh Delta at least
premium select or whatever would be
first class and Delta one would be lay
flat seats so for lay flat seats it's 8
283 dollars
for what would be first it was 4500 a
main cabin coach seat on wait 4500 first
but then does that lay down no oh that's
so weird about it
well it's just you can't lay down in
normal first you can only lay down I
think in like a Delta one or like and
it's only on like super long-haul
flights it's not just on I thought that
was the whole point
no yeah you can't lay down on all first
it's usually just like well if it's
International [__]
yeah but if you say keep the if I keep
the difference thing that we were
talking about before I'll I'll stay in
the [__] baggage area if I could keep
you pack me up in a suitcase yeah
so you said uh first class tickets you
can get for six thousand a piece
no it'd be 4 500. 4 500 that's
definitely worth it but is it it's it's
like the Delta first class right Sam
like the front of the plane it's not
like a
it's not like a private section right
like is it just a [__] it's I mean
it also just depends on the plane but
for what I'm looking at right now it's
4500 for premium select which is oh
premium selects [__] no it's not
it's that's not Comfort
what would be first class on like a
regular Point are you sure yeah premium
select sounds like a scam like oh you
get to select your seat and then you get
like one extra inch
it it's it really depends so much on the
plane though
all right so let's say
50 000 for the tickets
how much is it to stay in Tokyo like I
don't have no idea how much it costs for
a hotel there I don't know I didn't do
breakdowns I gave you just a rough okay
it's very expensive
how much was a normal coach ticket to
Japan like 15 1500 yep I just checked
again with a different date and I got
1500 again all right so here let's ELO
can you uh manage these numbers for me
going on so it's sick let's just say 20
000 for a flight
hold on
you see anything a five-star hotel in
Tokyo how much is it already twenty
thousand
[Music]
the Ritz Carlton Tokyo which that's as
good as it got sure is quite nice
seeing
709 900 a night
oh that's not okay so so that's
fantastic
then we would need since there's three
couples we would need what nine rooms
yeah something like that yeah so let's
just say it's a thousand a night we're
State we said we're staying for
what would be
eight nights
that's a lot that's not what we said all
right so we said we said six full days
so how many nights would you have at the
hotel
it was six full days seven probably to
say seven
okay so if it's seven day seven days
and there's we need how many rooms nine
rooms so seven times nine thousand
thousand a night
that's a sixty three thousand
[Music]
that's not bad where we're at
Parks everything let's throw in another
what do you say just to make sure that
it's like good the parks are what's
gonna
probably be the most expensive thing out
of that
really Parks here
yeah
what do you guys think uh for the food
and parks and stuff uh I don't know 50
less than that probably eh 25 000. sure
okay 25 000 so that that should cover
the whole trip right mm-hmm
so am I missing it's 108 I think it
would be more but I don't think 25 is
enough but yeah 2.2 2.2 K per person
yeah you're right double it so that's
another way too bad
all right so
130 000 for this trip to Japan damn
we're still under budget yeah okay guys
150 so I was in the ballpark yeah based
off of that so here's where it gets
interesting I will say I might want to
bring
makeup and photographer oh [__] all
right up to 150.
that would actually be killer content
yeah now here's where it gets
interesting my friends
this is the twist
mm-hmm Japan is the winner
and let's just say 150 000. okay
now here I you all must vote at this
time
do we all go to Japan
or
do you guys just keep the money
oh my God
now hold on hold on
at 150 000 divided by nine right that's
the correct number
yeah 16
000 per person
it has a lot of money
well we know what Zach feels now that
now the issue here is like how many
opportunities are we gonna get
to go to Japan like this like full
amazing life experience
but sixteen thousand dollars is
obviously a ton of money
so you all have to vote right now
right now you have my vote
so think about it you guys want to talk
it out amongst you guys want to talk it
out it's not fair for me and you to vote
right Ela because yeah that should be
them it should be them so you guys talk
it amongst yourselves you guys gotta
make a decision I mean I feel like
I feel like the obvious answer is like
everybody if you if we all took the
money you could just do the trip
like whatever trip you want
you know what I mean but not together
yeah but not together I guess I'll show
we got to consider taxes too if you take
the 16 000 you will get basically
40 to 50 percent of that
to spend on your trip
whereas if we go to Japan this is a full
business expense right so actually if
you did take the money
you would have half as much to spend on
your own vacation if you were to spend
it on the point
or even just to keep it for a Rolex Zach
you're getting a sixteen thousand dollar
value trip you could have about 50 of
that Zach I think I'd still rather take
the cash
does this have to go ahead does this
have to be a group decision or can some
people split no it's a group one
decision yeah it's all or nothing we're
all going
separately I'll fly you to Japan right
there will be tomatoes that yeah yeah
so this is easy for me initially when
you said it I was like I'm too fresh out
of poverty [__] it let's [__] do it
I'll take the cash
but now I don't know the value being
positioned to do the vacation yeah a lot
better the way that you you broke it
down with like the tax situation
everything I think I think my votes for
the trip I I think
money you could always make money but
think about it and then we'll do it
we'll do a vote are we gonna be able to
all do something like this together
that's true
it's very true I'm going on the trip 100
[__] yeah dude
all right so okay so I love you guys I
would love to do this you know what
[Music]
that's awesome okay
well does anybody vote to keep the money
other than Zach
don't be shy I mean it's a lot of money
I'm still thinking I you know trip and
by the way as a couple right as a couple
it's even more Ian and Sam and a b and
Lena that's thirty two thousand dollars
right as a couple
uh yeah that's that's a good point but
again Lenny thoughts half
I'm I just I'm with whatever I'm go with
the flow that's why I picked Australia
what everyone's got it she's got the
Aussie this isn't something I feel very
strongly about like I wish I was as
passionate as you guys were about all of
your plate your vacation spots
I see here's a donation from a Japanese
fan that says I'd love to see you guys
come here but I don't recommend the
summer it's humid and super hot and it's
miserable good morning baby
is
well I mean we're used to that's it yeah
yeah like it's super [__] hot here
yeah exactly I'm for we're from Israel
and L.A I doubt it's worse than that I
saw people posting on the sub that yeah
it's gonna be rainy too I'm working I
like rain warm rain sounds great it'll
be sunny in 85 in the Bahamas
well right right I love the Bahamas idea
for Japan for me I feel like it's an
awfully long way to go for a short time
I feel like if I would go to Japan I
would want to go for like two weeks yep
I feel like I would just need way longer
than than the amount of time well we'll
have six full days I still 12 hour
flight though you lose two like I don't
know I mean like yeah I get we'll have
six full days but I still feel like it's
awfully far
or since we've established a budget of
16 000 per person
what was the budget on the um
on the
it says in Japan and during its high 70s
low 80s that's something I love that
weather these people don't know what hot
is hot and humid I'm I'm a bit worried
about going to Japan because everyone
kind of want to do different stuff and
we're too big of a group well we'll make
a group itinerary we'll go we'll do it
all real nice
okay we'll have it all planned Thomas
might be more
um fun for everyone no matter what but
how much did we say the the Bahamas I
think you would set a hundred thousand
the lower end was 68 and then I was
adding all this extra [__] to be like
200 but we could have such a awesome
vacation before we do the Bahamas
that's safe four or five full days I
don't know what you're comfortable with
it's a lot less days so we're spending a
lot less money
you guys can keep the difference
of The Sixteen thousand I'm putting the
rest in that casino exactly so let's
just say that theoretically that would
leave you all with at least by my
calculation six thousand before taxes
before taxes obviously yeah
so that's another option
all right we're gonna vote you guys you
guys ready to vote we do need to erupt
this is binding this is it are we voting
between the two people yeah I'm so
confused now because like it didn't I'm
on what are we even voting on it would
have to be Japan I think is it money or
is it right it's confusing sorry yeah
it's money or Japan it's it's Japan then
so yeah money or Japan Zach go ahead
money
Sam
I'm gonna have to say money
Ian
I'm voting money
wow
this is this is uh snowballing Maybe
can I go last
maybe just
I'm voting for the trip so I'm just
throwing it out there me too that's two
to three Olivia
hold on hold on cam hold on hold on
Japan
maybe your vote you have to vote it's
3-3
Lena hold on hold on no ab's got to
decide well yeah I mean
yes ladies first it can be last yeah no
no that's a cop-out the man's got a vote
um it might help to know if he's like
the tie breaker I know he's trying to
scheme AB vote now
I want to know what he really wants
it's 3-3 you know what
because I know what this trip means to
Dan
I know
it's still money dancing can get paid
yeah I'm happy either way it doesn't
matter
so what do you want
what does a b want oh my God oh my God
so much pressure I can't do this oh my
God I vote Japan all right he loses his
boat all right Japan from Olivia we got
four wait did you oh you had a daughter
so wait that's four three four three and
that only leaves Lena and a b right go
ahead Lena you could decide uh next so
that money oh I was gonna pay money okay
four four
and now it's all on you it's all on your
shoulders do we go to Japan
or do we stay at home
50 taxes remember that guys
that proposition is crazy have you ever
wanted to go to Japan you'd it'll cost
you double
double
because this is pre-tax money you don't
get to take a company vacation to Japan
very often I'm sure can we get with the
chat can we do a poll to see what
everyone oh I'm sure they want us to go
to Japan they don't give a [__] if you
guys get money fair enough yeah we can
do a poll though
uh thanks Dan you want to go ahead and
do the poll
it's gonna be 99 yeah I just want to see
though yeah it's all up to a b who by
the way is wife
voted for the money
that is true it is true
but again the value proposition is
really tips Japan
88 says Japan
86. you know what
I gotta uh
go with the audience on this one and say
go to Japan what's final answer
final answer wow detention
that's it we're going to Japan then okay
let's [__] go
go all right we're doing we made it
Lena you're cheering pretty loud there
you're upvoted for the money
I mean they're both good options but now
like the thought that we're all going to
Japan that's real That's so exciting
good aab that was I'm telling you that
was a nail biter boy
there it is we're going to Japan I think
you guys made the right decision because
again
if you took eight thousand dollars and
which went to go a person and took that
to Japan
it wouldn't come anywhere near to the
[__] level of decadence right and
luxury that was my thinking we are going
because I had the thought I was like oh
just take the money and I'll just go to
Japan which would be fine I probably
still would do that if but half the
opportunity and I mean I agree that's
why I voted for the trip this is a legit
tax write-off so I mean like this this
is you know
yes sir
I'm not gonna sleep for the next week or
two but hell yeah let's do it
why why
I am never in my life the choice of uh
always a warranty between me and Lena
honestly the pressure was just too much
oh Lord
always overthinking yeah
no I I I I I I have there it is I have
to believe that one day money won't be a
problem and I love you guys I want to
have that experience
one day money won't you're fine money's
not a problem for you no it's not a
problem I mean come on but I mean like
we're eight or eight thousand won't mean
[__] right right a lot of money right
right
so there it is so after so then we got
to make start making arrangements
I guess so I have to start talking about
it well it sounds like almost none of us
have passports so um you guys we'll have
a we'll have that conversation mine is
expired but it's a lot easier to renew
but I'm more concerned about people that
just uh don't have one so everybody who
um
doesn't have or needs to renew I should
do it tomorrow Lena you should stay on
their ass to make sure they do it and
help them with whatever they shared I
would do if there's like an expressed
there is you can expedite it yeah
business related which we would say this
is because it is
um so I I I sometimes it's just an extra
fee is a renewal yeah yeah that's fine
we should do that all right so Lena you
want to take the point on that
and then in terms of taking the lead on
planning the itinerary Sam is that
something you feel you'd be good at
uh sure
I mean everyone can contribute but I
want one person to just be in charge
we can get the itinerary so we know what
we're doing every day I'm totally down
to get a tour guide who speaks Japanese
too
right
um
I think we gotta remember because I've
already done a bunch of research on it
so okay Dan yeah you want to take the
point yeah just because we're a big
group
yeah so
right like if we want to go eat at a
restaurant we're a really big group yeah
everything will need to be I agreed yeah
and we'll we'll get all on top of that
there you go and I'll provide moral
support hell yeah thank you Cam you got
this Dan I believe in your egg scan you
got this thing buddy
good luck I'm I'm curious is the flight
thing actually still on the table like
where if we take a cheaper flight
because I'll fly this year this man is
gonna have himself in a FedEx box to
Japan that was never on the table
I don't know what yeah how what there's
no you want to fly coach I mean that's
the lowest option that's what I'm
offering okay
I wasn't sure if you guys were going to
fly a first class that's why uh
oh oh I guess I I don't I think that was
for I think that's for a different area
maybe we were talking about I think it
was Bahamas we were saying if we go
cheaper okay yeah but okay so this is
happening we're hap we're going to Japan
well they're gonna do the live show and
then our break begins and our Venture
begins hell yeah there it is
thank you bbtv
I forgot it's during that two weeks
yeah
it's okay yay you want to say do you
want to change your vote no no no you
can't do it you forgot what that it's
during our official vacation time oh
well someone said why is Ethan still
hold on hold on hold on why is Ethan
being so stingy
that's what they said why is Ethan being
so stingy you guys know this money has
nothing to do with us right yeah this is
literally for all expenses paid trip to
another country what made you just say
that that's crazy I just I'm just
curious like the only thing that could
have caused it is because at first he
said like come up with your trip There's
No Limit that's why we voted for the
best one yeah and just so you guys know
it was true I don't know if the audience
knows that but how many times we've had
something that made a lot of money and
Ethan's let the crew keep it this year
alone is probably four or five times
between the Cards and this and that
thanks bro yep that's true thank you
goofy don't be goofy thank you guys I am
genuinely curious what made you say that
but after they're just trolling uh there
it is so okay this is very exciting guys
this is awesome
let's [__] do this [__] dude let's
[__] go right now is everyone excited
because they said 620 down to 150 so
uh they feel that
we should spend every dollar
but at the end of the day it is 100 our
money as uh Dan pointed out yeah y'all
can [__] suck my tiny Jewish dick
right you [__] he's nuts
um all right we have been going for four
and a half hours holy crap yeah get the
[__] out of here I feel like you
presenting the option kind of took the
excitement out is everyone excited
yeah definitely yeah oh this is uh this
is a once in a lifetime opportunity
let's [__] go I'm excited I'm excited
no I'm telling you it's gonna be dude
we're gonna make sure that we go all out
nicest hotels nicest food we're gonna do
everything it's gonna be [__] awesome
dude it's gonna be great
all right that's it then that's it thank
you guys for watching good job everybody
who presented Dan I gotta say
a good presentation going to Japan today
I don't think you did either I didn't
really expect to be uh that persuasive
but looks like we got there
you can see Ethan halfway through the
presentation yeah I was yeah I was
captivated by it it sounded like I was
less worried about Ila because I I knew
about the established desire uh to go
there uh from that clip and everything
but
I wasn't sure if I'd be able to sell you
on it but oh Chris Bernie said AB made
the right choice with peace and love
there you go it did there you go I think
I'll buy a car there
an important car there no no joke I've
been wanting to go to La Japan and buy a
car okay just so you know
when you bring it back you have to pay
the sales tax or even more an import tax
of probably
I've researched this for literally seven
years it's cheaper to go buy it in Japan
well yeah way cheaper yeah what yeah
you're missing something I'm sure JDM
Cars it's interesting really
really rare all right we should talk
about that love all right guys have a
great weekend thank you everybody wow
exciting times all right it's all
happening
here at the History podcast
[Music]